the average American dies overweight
alone and broke we sure as don't want to
be the average you can definitely make
your first million in a 9 to5 easier
than you can an entrepreneur go steal
somebody else's homework and learn on
their dime instead of your own every
action you take either makes or loses
money for a company how much profit do
you make the company because that's how
you figure out how to negotiate to earn
more we were taught budgeting and saving
and don't have Starbucks and I don't
believe in any of that what is your
advice for people who want to become
rich I think the best advice for people
that are young is simply this idea of
well there you have it everybody there's
the recipe to become rich Cody Sanchez
this has been a long time coming you're
extremely impressive I've seen you on
quite a few different podcasts every
single time they blow up just because
you're so knowledgeable and everyone
loves you thank you for coming on the
iced coffee I really appreciate it my
pleasure I'm excited to be here guys so
I'm curious why should people listen to
You O I mean you shouldn't really I
don't think you should listen to anybody
on the internet question everything is
actually our motto at contrarian
thinking but one of the reasons that I
like talking on the Internet is that I
don't think enough people talk about the
fact that the most important thing for
any human is ownership in one shape or
form so I don't think you have to listen
to me but I do think you should listen
to more people who say you're capable
and you can do it and you should have
skin in the game as opposed to a CA or a
chorus of humans these days that tell
you all the reasons why you can't and
you're a victim and it's not possible
especially in this world today what
qualifies you well I guess I could give
my background depends on what you
shouldn't listen to me about anything to
do with cooking cleaning um but when it
comes to finance and investing I've been
doing it a long time and so you know if
you I think the best predictor of future
behavior is past Behavior right and in
my career I've been in finance since
2008 so a long time worked at Goldman
Sachs works at State Street worked at
Vanguard built a billion-dollar Asset
Management business at a company called
First Trust in Latin America and so I
don't know a lot of things but I know a
lot about how to invest and how to do it
in the private Equity side of the field
which is where I've spent most of my
life yeah so if that's interesting then
maybe you want to listen to me um but no
I don't profess that uh anybody on the
internet should be listened to 100% of
the time and you guys are probably the
same way yeah how did you get started
doing all that like what was your life
like growing up like most young people I
think nobody has won career and set path
I think this idea of linear career
progression is completely false and if
you've talked to anybody who's had any
real success all they've done
consistently and linearly is fail
continuously and so I was the same way I
started out thinking that I wanted to be
in politics I worked under a a
senatorial campaign then I thought that
I might want to be a lawyer so I worked
for the rule 11 competency Court which
is um somewhere that you go to determine
if you should become a war of the state
or not and then I went into journalism
and I covered human trafficking along
the US Mexico border for a period of
years and then finally I think all of
this I was trying to Circle this around
if you see what's kind of consistent
throughout it it's like rule of
incompetency Court Freedom like should
you be in charge of your future or
should you not politics comes down to
Freedom human trafficking certainly the
ultimate freedom and what I kind of
realized is um that I think the only
real Freedom stems from money that I
think the international language that
allows freedom is green and uh that most
power comes from do you understand and
do you have money and if you do in this
day and age you can control a lot of
things and so because of that I went
from becoming a journalist to well I
want to understand this stuff I didn't
have any money I didn't know anything
about investing at the time I come from
a family of very humble background my
mom was a 30-year special education
teacher father um you know didn't get a
chance to go to college immigrated to
the US and uh and so I climbed up up the
ranks of Finance so maybe a little bit
different than other people on the
internet although you guys have been sh
here on he's similar I had a lot of
traditional jobs for a long time before
I decided to do anything on the
interwebs were you always inquisitive as
a kid because it seems as though you're
very curious about things so I know we
talk a lot about financial success
you're on the channel but honestly
what's even more important is the mental
aspect that goes right alongside with it
our sponsor better help is the world's
largest therapy service used by over 4
million people and with over 30,000
licensed therapists within their Network
you'll get access to a wide range of
expertise with helpful unbiased advice
so I've mentioned this before but I've
had ADHD my entire life and I've always
struggled with it it's a constant battle
if you have ADHD you know exactly what
I'm talking about but actually after a
few sessions with my better help
therapist I understood it way better and
actually how I can leverage my ADHD to
my advantage to start all you got to do
is fill out a questionnaire to help
address your specific needs and then
from there you'll get matched with a
therapist often in 48 hours or less
better help is also extremely simple to
use you can talk to your therapist via
text chat phone or video call and you
can even message your therapist at any
time or schedule live sessions when it's
convenient for you plus if for any
reason your therapist isn't the right
fit and trust me I've had a few
therapists and some of them have not
been the right fit you can actually
switch to a new therapist at no
additional cost which is a huge benefit
so if you're interested in getting
started with betterhelp click the link
Down Below in the description or visit
betterhelp.com iedc Cofe hour and get
10% off your first month of therapy
again the link is down below in the
description to get started today and now
let's get back to the episode were you
always inquisitive as a kid because it
seems as though you're very curious
about things Curiosity has always been
an underpinning I would take a curious
Optimist over a brilliant pessimist any
day of the week and it's one of our core
principles for hiring at our our firm
but um you guys have a podcast because
it is actually a beautiful thing when
you get a chance to ask humans who have
some sort of specialty how they got
there why they got there what they
learned and so um I learned from an an
early age we used to have these four
chairs in my parents uh living room and
we have them to this day when I have
kids I have this theory of four chairs
which is basically our family would get
together and instead of watching TV
after dinner we would sit down and we
would talk about what happened today and
we would kind of debate a lot of
politics
a l of principles philosophy and so from
a young I got Prett comfort with why do
you believe that idea what is the
underlying first principles thinking in
that idea well if you believe this Jack
like what would be the second and third
effects of thinking that way and um and
a funny thing happens when you ask
questions continuously I think it
becomes an addiction and that addiction
actually can lead to a lot of
intellectual progress because all you're
doing is trying to figure out root truth
root truth root truth and uh so I I
really owe it a lot to those four chairs
I think yeah were you a good student
seems like a lot of entrepreneurs kind
of rebel against school was that you
threw my first protest at 15 so I think
it depends on you mean you threw your
first protest what were you protesting I
was protesting uh what I think it was
some rule at the time where we weren't
allowed to they wanted to limit our in
between hours you guys remember what
that was called like so you go to class
and then you'd have a break in between
the administration wanted to limit that
they yes the administration like a lunch
or like a like a no it's like in between
each class you had like 10
minutes passing period there we go and
they wanted to limit it from 15 minutes
to 10 or something like that and I think
like most high performers it's very hard
to sit still for you know an hour plus
listening to a lecture on history from a
teacher uh who you know doesn't have a
speaking ability and so I struggled in
school with being able to focus so I
threw my first protest to say that's
ridiculous like we already are sitting
for cumulative 5 hours a day or
something like that we should be able to
move in between uh classes and so that
was that was my I was 15 and how do you
throw a protest do you get your friends
together or like what do you do also you
said most high performers have a hard
time listening to teachers that just
kind of like Ramble On were you a high
performer at the time I was a high
performer in that I was you know a
straight A student the parents
definitely had an expectation yeah now I
didn't love school and I think similar I
think I'm a little bit unschool and
unemployable at this this stage like
most entrepreneurs are um hard to stay
focused always questioning wondering why
we're not doing X instead of Y but um
but at the time you know when I threw a
first protest which is a great thing for
people to do at a young age I think you
um you learn are you willing to take a
stand are you willing to fail are you
willing to put yourself out there but
basically I got a bunch of my friends
together we created poster boards I
don't know if they still had those back
in the day we went on a little strike
out front of the school campus and it
was a smaller town in Arizona called
Arcadia and uh yeah we got some press
coverage and then eventually you know
the the principal at the time um sat
down with me which was really
interesting to hear what were my
complaints and why do we think this one
way or the other and so um yeah so that
was that was the first happen did they
they gave us the five minutes back they
did won I won yeah now that doesn't
always happen but why did they want to
take it down five minutes was it just
because they wanted more school time or
they we're thinking kids are kind of
like corporate overreach you know I'd
imagine just kids just kind of hanging
out maybe wasting time in between class
you know Idle Hands Are The Devil's play
toy right and so I think from a from a
facilitator's perspective people who
have power always want more power is the
core thesis of my life I think and that
tends to be true with school teachers
just as much as it's true with
politicians and so in this case what is
easier to manage a group of students who
are all on one location with in
independent supervisors much easier than
when students are Milling about in
between doing what they will and so I I
think there's this fundamental balance
between you know safety and freedom that
always happens when you have structures
and so in that instance of course they
go hey kids aren't very safe in between
their smoking you know cigarettes
they're leaving campus they're getting
into fights and so we could decrease
that if they were just a little less
free and uh I think instead of doing
that we should actually teach people how
to make the right decisions through
correct incentives as opposed to
limitations did you ever get in trouble
as a kid for sure for
what let's see I wasn't as bad as a lot
of kids I wasn't a big drinker or drug
user or anything like that but I do
remember my father good good lesson for
any fathers out there did plant a row of
cactuses in front of my window for a
long time I thought that he was a an
avid Gardener and it turns out there was
a secondary reason for cactuses in front
of my window which is uh I did sneak out
I snuck out of the house and got in
trouble and got caught for doing it so
that was my why you sneak out of the
house I'm sure meeting a boy you know
young girl um going and causing some
Shenanigans so I'm curious when I think
back to high school you can kind of
point out the people that you think are
going to be extremely successful later
in life were you somebody that people
around you were like oh yeah that Cody
Sanchez girl like she's definitely going
to be extremely wealthy could anyone
have guessed that eventually down the
line you'd be running a or owning a
bunch of different businesses making
famously like just under $100 million a
year well um I never took no for an
answer which is a beautiful thing to do
I think at a young age to always ask why
why why instead of just complying yes
but in the high school yearbook I wasn't
valedictorian you know I didn't have the
traditional path that you saw from like
a Ben Shapiro or a Vivic ramaswami where
they just had such a high intellectual
grade early that it was noted that at
some point these individuals were going
to go on to big things I think mine was
more Brute Force you know I don't like
no and I want to keep working until we
solve the problem as opposed to take
things at face value and so that was
probably the difference but um I sort of
have an underlying belief that intellect
isn't as important as uh never quitting
and that entrepreneurship is
95% grit and 5% skills and talent for
most of us and I think that was Apparent
at a young age it's interesting we've
been hearing that a lot lately actually
that it doesn't really take intellect
yeah well I mean they say that there's I
mean there's a lot of research that
shows that um up until a point you know
it's it's like any bell curve right on
either side of the bell curve you have
on the low very very low end of the IQ
curve that is very difficult to then
succeed so there is some level of
intellect that is necessary in order to
succeed but actually at the very high
end of the bell curve it's harder to
succeed by and large um because social
norms are so important and so instead of
you know trying to optimize like I think
we all did at a young age how high are
my SATs what college am I going to get
into am I smart enough it's really you
know we were doing some research the
other day for companies because we're
always looking at how do we determine
the best people to hire at any time and
when it comes to high performance
what we found through looking at a
myriad of studies is two which is Angela
Duckworth's work on grit so you know do
you continue to go for it even in the
likely event of failure and then the
secondary was interesting it's actually
um it's actually behavioral aggression
so if you were to come to me and say you
get to pick between High performers and
figure out which one you think will be
more likely to succeed the most likely
to succeed typically has this thing
called Behavioral aggress ression which
basically is similar to what you see in
sports let's say um it's typical to what
you see in dating and it sort of holds
consistent across both business dating
and uh things like sports it which is
simply how aggressive are you do you
continue to ask questions do to continue
to try to go hard after the things you
want and that is a much better indicator
for Success than raw intellect which I
thought was interesting so you got good
grades in high school then you went off
to college I'm guessing right that's the
next thing in the timeline how'd you do
in college well I mean I went to the
Harvard of the west Arizona State
University which is not known for its
intellectual prowess at all what do you
mean Harvard of the West it's the
opposite of that it was J it a joke
maybe there maybe there's a class in
there not on my radar um no Harvard
isn't uh is nothing like ASU um but uh
you know if I had one regret in life it
would be that I listened to my parents
who said just go for the school we get
into for free go play safe you know
don't go too far from the family instead
if I could listen to any other advice it
would be you know shoot your shot in
every sense of the Lord in every way
possible try to go for the hardest and
best and highest thing that you possibly
can and so instead of that they said go
to ASU because you get in and it's free
and I said okay that seems reasonable so
I went to ASU and yeah I got good grades
but I mean the classes at ASU I think I
took a history of Elvis Presley class I
took a beatle 1 two and three you know
this is not rigorous why do they teach
you that they have to but why it's all a
part of undergrad I you have to do all
the prerequisite classes you have to get
though why I took history of
jazz seems more sophisticated for it
really isn't it sounds sophisticated but
it's not the professor would eat hot
dogs during the middle of the lecture
that's incredible yeah and then I one
day he forgot he was eating a hot dog
put it on top of the piano taught the
rest of the lecture and left the room he
forgot he was eating a hot dog so what
happened to the hot dog I don't know I
left with the professor probably justed
go to
Har finish that I should have asked yeah
you only ate half of it there was plenty
left I don't know why they make you
teach or they they teach you those
lectures I don't think it's important so
weird it's just a part I think a lot of
what it is and for the credit of college
it teaches you how to study how to learn
and how to have grit kind of like what
you said I mean like learning something
you don't necessarily want to be
learning and pushing through that is a
skill and I think actually that's where
most of the benefit from college comes
from is pushing through that right I
mean the there's fascinating data out
there and it's hard to get data out of
2022 but the last data I saw said as of
2010 if you have a high school diploma
versus a college degree you are going to
earn somewhere around $3 million more
over the lifetime earnings of an
individual with a college degree than a
high school grad degree and so you'll
earn about a million you'll earn about
four at the high end so just looking at
the stats you would say college has a
high Roi we should go to college but one
I think that data is outdated over the
next 10 years we're going to see that
materially change and two I think um the
two things that we are told about
college right is that it will prepare
you for the real world so this is your
Preparatory class for in business in
life whatever the next stage may be and
the second thing when they say that they
can't quite prove that one anymore is
it's the network right and that's
especially true I think for
MB and I went to MBA at Georgetown
and I don't talk to anybody that I went
to MBA at Georgetown with because
actually it's not that hard school when
you're contextually young seems hard and
then how many of us actually think
school looks hard when we've run a
business when you can't pay payroll when
you're close to bankruptcy when you did
a deal and it's going to fail when you
can't bring any Revenue when you got to
tell your friends and family that you
aren't making money School actually
seems quite easy by comparison and so I
think the network only actually comes by
doing hard things which is why all of my
friends now are former business owners
current business owners because we've
been through difficulty together and I
actually don't think school teaches you
that at all so I got good grades at ASU
but what does it actually matter what
about the college experience was that
worth it I mean a lot of frat parties
and uh tailgates for me um it's fun you
know Georgetown was fun too it's
beautiful campus both experiences are
super fun and if my kids want to go
there you know I will certainly let them
do so but do I think that they might be
better served by going out and actually
starting a business themselves or going
out and working at a few startups Yeah
by and large minus the fact that I do
think that we should have an in a base
level understanding of philosophy like
how do you think you want to show up in
the world what are good ethics and
values um what does it mean to have a
successful life what is the definition
of winning what do you want to
accomplish before you die that you might
not learn how to start up and so I do
think we have to teach children those
Classics but I'm not so sure that
college actually does that anymore it's
interesting that you bring brought up
the data that I felt like everybody has
seen where if you graduate college
you're going to make 3 million times
more than someone who doesn't they use
that as like a weapon against us in my
public high school where like everybody
then felt like they needed to go to
college if they were going to provide
yeah why do you think that is well
historically it made sense yeah but like
today do you think that still applies no
absolutely not I think in the future I
mean we're already seeing it I was just
on the news next yesterday and I did a
bunch of research on it so it's top of
mind and I can hopefully get the numbers
right but you know today I think
categorically more CEOs will hire from
Twitter and product hunt than they will
from universities I think receipts are
bigger than resumes we want you to not
tell us what you've accomplished but
show us think about the members of your
team I have no idea where Tanner went to
school uh I actually don't even know if
you finished College probably not I
don't even know his last name did you
finish college okay there we go his
mom's like what the um so uh you
know those are not things that I ask
anymore and um what I actually want to
see is show me your proof of work and so
I think in the future that will be a
huge differentiat and we're already
seeing it at a lot of the major firms I
mean I was going back and forth with
bology the other day who's you know kind
of a categorical genius and we were
joking he's like well aren't you kind of
a hypocrite because you went to
Georgetown for an MBA but you're telling
people that MB don't have a high Roi and
shouldn't do it like Ivory Tower much
and they said well I went to Georgetown
in
2013 and so I suppose that that's the
same year that Google Glass came out I
suppose my degree from Georgetown
University is worth just about as much
today as a Google Glass from 2013 is
worth which is categorically nothing I
don't actually find that there's huge
value in it today I heard something
recently too I think it was zip
recruiter 55% of their applications no
longer require a bachelor's degree so
the majority of degrees out there and I
think I even heard overall just outside
of zip recruiter it was 45% of all jobs
no longer require a bachelor's degree
yeah I mean doesn't surprise me if you
look at the trades you know the average
welder makes somewhere around
$172,000 a year now that's a highlevel
trade that is Tak some apprenticeship in
order to learn the average marketing
degree makes anywhere from 37 to $65,000
a year and requires a college degree and
so it's just math you know when you look
at the math if the creep of degrees has
increased at a level that is outpaced
their level of utility from an earnings
perspective then we should question it
more and so I wouldn't be surprised if
in the next 20 to 30 years schools have
to categorically change or um they need
to start getting stop giving Government
funding or they need to increase uh
decrease the amount that they increase
their um tuition every year so to
continue the timeline you graduate
college and then you go to all of these
different random jobs that you mentioned
in the beginning and then eventually you
find yourself going into finance and
becoming what was it like an investment
banker financial analyst or something at
my first job was Vanguard yeah so I
joined their accelerated development
program which is a great hack if you're
young and I think a lot of people these
days say don't go to corporations I
actually disagree with that I think you
could even skip the university as often
as you want but if you can get into a
corporation they actually pay you to get
a mini MBA I went to Vanguard and had to
take all of these licenses in order to
get um Securities trained uh in order to
invest and then we would go around
different divisions of the company and I
would have different jobs every I think
it was every two months or three months
it was an 18-month program and
relatively hard to get into but almost
every large corporation has this so um
if you go to to deoe to DuPont to
vangard you can join their accelerated
development program and so I did and I
did that for about 24 months two years
something like that um before I realized
that some companies are also super
socialist and Vanguard is one of those
it's an incredible company if you want
to stay forever and you don't want to
progress quickly and you don't want to
have a meritocracy where you make money
depending on how much you provide value
to the compy
Vanguard is technically a nonprofit and
so uh because of that I didn't stay
there very long as Cody talks about in
the episode running a successful
business requires that you have the
right people and the right systems in
place to get the job done and thankfully
with her sponsor Shopify you can get all
of that and more for the low cost of
just $1 Shopify is the global e-commerce
platform that has already helped
transform millions of businesses
worldwide for example Shopify is an
endless list of Integrations thirdparty
apps and flexible templates to customize
your store exactly how you want it and
what set Shopify apart from their
competitors is their ability to turn
browsers into buyers with the internet's
best converting checkout that's 36%
better on average than leading
competitors on top of that Shopify also
Powers 10% of all e-commerce Platforms
in the United States including Brands
like Alberts rothy and Brooklyn and in
over 175 countries in fact my coffee
company bankr coffee is run exclusively
through Shopify and initially when we
were getting started up there's no other
competitor it was just Shopify that was
the only platform that we even
considered using because they're that
good plus they have an award-winning
support team to help you every step of
the way so sign up for their $1 per
month trial period guys it's only $1 per
month at shopify.com all lowercase or
visit the link Down Below in the
description again the link is down below
in the description to get started with
just $1 it's a dollar guys thank you so
much and now let's get back to the
episode how does that make sense a
company that only makes money by moving
money how is it a socialist company well
there is is a this is slightly technical
but guard's interesting because they're
actually a mutual holding company and
they patented this unique structure that
allows all additional profits to go back
and to decreasing their fees and so
that's why we see such low fees from
Vanguard exchange traded funds and was
patented by the CEO of the company at
the time that I was there and he got
zero dollars for that patent by the way
because he worked at the company which
is fascinating and so um Vanguard
operates on a principle that I think is
true which is most people want safety
they don't want upside and so people
stay at Vanguard for decades and decades
because they get a percentage of the
profit share and they are comfortable
living a life where they're highly
unlikely to ever get fired Vanguard does
not have mass layoffs they've never had
them and so if you want to choose safety
versus upside a company like Vanguard is
interesting I just didn't I said I'd
rather have an a likelihood to get fired
but make more how much were they paying
their employees like is it like a good
like six figures 100 Grand a year 37k a
year 36k a year or something like that
my first generally going to be upside
like you you definitely make more than
$36,000 a year but you could go look up
on the Internet definitely the CEOs of
Vanguard and one of the lowest paid uh
SE Suite individuals in the country for
sure and they are the one of the largest
Asset Management firms in the world and
so it is not dollar for dooll better pay
and and I think there's a lot of virtue
signaling that goes on in companies like
that too like because the guy who who
founded that company called Jack Bogle
back in the day right you know he still
drove similar to Warren Buffett
incredible publicist honestly uh still
drove his Camry or Buick sort of similar
story every single day and then
simultaneously um lived in his same
house and so I remember at Vanguard back
in the day you would see managers who
would have a a timax and a Buick or
something that they would drive into
work and then you'd see them on the
weekends and they'd have the rolls and
they'd you know have their nice BMW or
whatever um and I just I like having
congruency in life it makes it a lot
easier to remember things if you life so
you found that they really tried to
subdue or hide their wealth from the
employees was that more sort of a
jealousy thing or a principle like
here's what we stand for here's the
image that we portray cultures of
companies are just Cults right and so
you know in my belief if you have a good
culture in a company you have a
cult-like company and what does a cult
necessitate uh socialized Norms
behaviors Creeds and sometimes dress
often dress and so I think vanguard's
cult was one of
we are value based you know we don't
we're not showy um we don't try to have
more for me we have more for we and so
because of that yeah I think they had to
normalize to the cult like behavior of
the company what did you decide to leave
and what was the Catalyst for that
because it sounds like a pretty cushy
job all things considered vanguard's a
great company I'm sure you get amazing
benefits there amazing benefits and
learned a lot that's why I think those
rotational programs are a great place to
start and a terrible place to die you
want to leave somewhere between so that
you can continue to progress and a lot
of people don't they get trapped in the
sea of safety but um I actually left
because of one man which is often true I
think people leave jobs but they really
leave bosses right and so my boss shout
out Ron uh nice enough guy but um you
know I wanted to move quickly and so I
came up with a an idea for a division at
Vanguard and at the end of how an
accelerated program works is you have
like 20 of us or whatever it was and at
the end of your Accel ated program you
get placed in a division somewhere
within the company permanently right and
I wanted a placement to run investments
in Latin America low level right I'm a
nobody at that stage but I'm like I
think we could do this here's how I can
you know start this one I'm going to
division other under this other one over
here I'm going to come up with my own
job and I did that and I gave it to Ron
and Ron ran it up the food chain and
they said yes to this idea but then uh
which has long been a thing I've been
bad at um but then I remember like very
uh like it was yesterday he sat me down
and he said you know we've agreed to
move forward on this position I'm so
excited I'm going to go do something in
Latin America on the investing side and
he was like um however I wanted to ask
you what are your peers think of you I'm
like what I don't I thought we were
talking about this long story short he
goes uh I think uh your peers have said
that you would leave dead bodies behind
you to get ahead and I was like
literally figuratively you know I'm kind
of like a it was like 120 blonde chick
back then um like probably couldn't do
that what do you mean and he's like and
so he starts to peel back the layers and
it's that I didn't show up for company
parties and I you know kind of only
worked I was at my desk all the time I
was dismissive of people if they came by
because I was on the phones I was
focused on work I was like a very
focused individual and it's sort of like
that duck on the surface right you know
I came from nothing Harvard of the West
ASU I didn't have the fancy backgrounds
these people did I didn't know what a
mutual fund was when it started so on
the surface I might have looked okay but
I was I was paddling and uh and
so anyway they ended up giving the job
to somebody else but you created it but
I created the job wow I was pissed and
in retrospect he did me an incredible
favor because what that led to is me
saying okay so culture really matters in
your career the company that you choose
is important the company's culture is
incredibly important for career
advancement so where do I find find a
company where dead bodies are okay where
they just want me to be a meritocracy
and win and to do it ethically and
morally but that it's okay to really
focus on winning and that would be a
seen as a good thing not a bad thing and
so I found Goldman Sachs and it was a
natural progression to Goldman because I
found a culture where they were like we
win you know and we do it ethically and
morally but we win and so I left to go
there how do you just up and leave and
pick Goldman Sachs what's the
application process like is it difficult
want to get a job at a top tier company
which I don't know if kids even want
that anymore but if you want a job at a
top tier company and you want to get
there fast the secret is to find the
recruiters who recruit for that company
and so I'm always looking for my who not
my how and my who uh was Finding who the
recruiters were for Goldman and so I
went out and typically all Financial
firms have third party recruiters that
recruit for them so if you want to go
work at a big Investment Bank you find
the recruiter that recruits analysts at
that level and so I found one I reached
out to a ton of them and then I found
one this guy by the name of Taran who
was incredible who coached me because
they make money when they place you
right the average placement fee in
finance is $100,000 for an analyst level
role what M they pay you almost equal to
the first year salary of an analyst well
they did back then I don't know if they
do anymore that's insanely high so just
recruit people to just recruit an
individual to pay that much it depends
how long the person stays and what
they're able to get the contract for so
do these people get paid if you sign a
year-long contract and you leave like a
year and a day into it I don't know okay
uh and the contracts are highly variable
and I think you know back then they also
had metrics woman Latina quota higher
and that would pay differently on the
recruitment yeah I don't even know if
that's legal anymore but uh so I found
Taran he helped prep me for the
interview because recruiters do get paid
every time and even if they don't get
paid that amount like right now we pay
recruiters who find a c-level Executives
anywhere from 60 to $80,000 per se-l
executive um and if we have more junior
level hires those hires typically make
somewhere around 3 months of the salary
of the hire of the hire and so that can
be really lucrative for recruiters um so
I found that guy and he helped me get in
the door at Goldman but it was 10 12
interviews you know presentations and
hours of prep to get there just curious
when you were working at Vanguard you
said you were working extremely
intensely and you weren't rewarded for
it is this something that you always
were this level of intensity because I
know for a lot of viewers they hear from
people like you and they're like I just
don't have what it takes I don't have
what what she says she does day in day
out she'd clock in she'd just grind all
day is there something that you think
like maybe because you're from like a
family of immigrants or like this is
just something you were naturally born
with it's like in your genes I tend to
believe every human has that thing that
they are meant to do that they
completely lose track of time in I heard
you guys talking about this with another
podcast member I am annoyed when
somebody interrupts my flow state of
work I am grumpy I don't like it um and
i' much rather be obsessing on the
things I want to do at work than doing
97% of things in life and I tend to
think that every person has that It's
just tough to find what it is you know
I've been through probably seven or
eight different careers because each
time it wasn't there it wasn't right it
wasn't right and so I think the sad part
about humans is that we think that we
have to stay in jobs we don't like doing
things we don't want to do for decades
because that's what work is and that's
why people have like an anti work anti-
hustle culture but man if you find a
thing you love to do doesn't mean
everyday is fun there's many many
miserable miserable days but it does
mean um that you can lose track of time
in it just as easily as you can run a
meditation or an orgasm yeah what did
you do at Goldman Sachs exactly I did
many things at Goldman Sachs when I
first went into Goldman Sachs I worked
in what was called the Gan the Goldman
Sachs Asset Management Group and so they
brought us in there and basically at the
time so this this was right pre
crisis so we sold Investments to
institutions that Goldman had and that
was fun I did that for a period and then
I went to pep which is the private
Equity Group um and I think they spun
that off actually so then we sold
Goldman Sachs private Equity products to
other institutions and then I went into
the investment banking analyst program
and I had two choices Investment Banking
analyst program is interesting it's like
a two-year program something like that
but the problem was when I was at
Goldman we were during the financial
crisis and so they they fired uh every
year they fired 20% of the uh of the
employees at Goldman Sachs um it's part
of their churn process or at least it
was back then and um and I thought they
were going to have to spin out the
investment bank because they were under
huge scrutiny and so I had a decision do
I stay in the investment banking side
and move forward with that or do I go to
this other Vision which was the private
wealth Division and so I was deciding
between that there was a lot of stuff
going on at Goldman at the time and then
I chased a man to Dallas instead and
left the firm uh because I wanted to be
out of the Dallas office and they didn't
have Investment Bank in there and they
only had a segment of private wealth I
didn't want to do how did you find the
man he was he worked at Goldman too yeah
so that was my first husband I'm I'm
divorced and remarried um but we both
worked there at the same time and so um
so he ended up going and working on a
different firm in Dallas and I you know
I kind of put my my career as a back
burner and and followed in hindsight do
you regret that decision no because well
the only decision decision I ever regret
is when I didn't strive for the really
big huge thing that I wanted and um so
when I decided to move to Dallas I'm
actually glad I didn't stay in
Investment Banking I think that was an
incredible career for people you know 20
years ago and increasingly Investment
Banking to me was less interesting than
than private equity and so instead um I
think you should step change in your
career as often as you can you sort of
skill stack like Adam Scott talks about
right you try to get as many disperate
types of skills as you can because it's
really hard to be Lance Armstrong or to
be you know Tiger Woods but it's not
that hard to be somebody who has an
amalgamation of many talents and so I'm
I don't regret that decision uh because
I went and aggressively pursued another
another job which was State Street at
the time um and I did the institutional
Development Group there and so you know
if there's a Common Thread it's
basically these days we hear a lot of
entrepreneurial stories that go like
this it was really hard I didn't make
any money I almost left everything lost
everything so then I slept on my couch
and then something took off and then I
worked really hard on that something and
then I kept going right I think that's a
lot of entrepreneurial stories these
days but I think there's a huge segment
of humans out there that are working in
nineo fives and don't realize you can
definitely make your first million in a
9o5 actually I think easier than you can
an entrepreneur because because there's
already systems and processes in place
now making your first 10 million plus
hard to do uh if you don't become an
entrepreneur but your first million in a
job I think is actually much easier and
then you can have a cushion of which to
propel yourself through the rest of your
career I think a big disservice we do to
entrepreneurs today is we tell them you
know go now take a huge risk now you
don't know anything when you're first
starting out go steal somebody else's
homework and learn on their dime instead
of your own um and then you can have a
cushion for when you want to take the
huge jump and you might fall but you'll
be okay so when you were working at
Goldman you said that your income would
be reflective of your production yeah
how did that look for you then when you
finally felt like you were contributing
to that yeah oh well I mean There Is No
Greater Joy I think than
seeing output done or activity done and
dollar made I think it's like a great
joy in business if anybody likes video
games it's the same thing in business
it's like you know how do you guys feel
when you see a video start to take off
that you spent time on how do you guys
feel when you have a product and it
starts to sell it is beautifully
addicting and so uh I think that's where
I first got addicted to this game of
business was seeing at Goldman Sachs
okay if I make this much in one of our
funds uh for our investors here's what I
get paid here's a dollar Ford dooll
amount if I make you know this much by
bringing in this many investors here's
what I make and so you know for our
companies that contr and thinking
Capital we try to have incentive aligned
pay for every single person we can even
down to like an admin because I want to
instill in people this idea that every
action you take either makes or loses
money for a company and you should
really understand if you're an employee
are you a cost center or a profit Center
and if you are a profit Center you
should figure out how much profit do you
make the company because that's how you
figure out how to negotiate to earn more
and I learned that at Goldman so how
much were you making at Goldman and how
how was your income affected by your um
towards the end of Goldman probably a
couple hundred thousand oh that's wow
that's a lot of money and how old were
you at the time uh I was in 20s early
20s that's insane well you made money at
Goldman off of two things at Goldman and
most of these Financial firms you make
money off of salary which is really not
that high I don't remember let's call it
$100,000 $120,000 something like that
and then bonus and bonus at that time
was individually tied to how much money
you're bringing in and so if I brought
in x amount of you know dollars from
investors I got a percentage of every
single dollar I brought in uncapped
upside which is I think where anybody
should be so safe to say you were
successful at that position yeah and do
you think that gave you a lot of
confidence then going in when you
started buying your own businesses oh
for sure I mean the good thing about
Goldman a couple different things once
you have a few pennies to rub together
and then you can take those first
pennies and make it on your own outside
of your 9-to-5 I think that is probably
the the single biggest trigger point for
Freedom it's like how people talk about
you make your first dollar on the
internet and that makes life a lot
easier and I think that was the same
thing for me at that company I made a
couple pennies and I started investing
in the stock market in 2008 well we had
an economist back in the day that had a
great line he would speak to a bunch of
our investors and and they'd say what
stock should I invest in right now in
2008 and he would say yes they like no
no what he's like pick a stock any stock
because we're at rock bottom level
prices right so I started investing
pretty heavily in the stock market at
that point and that ended up being a
really good bet at the bottom of the
market so your position at Goldman was
it investing in public companies
deploying Capital there was it more so
like buying up smaller businesses and
stuff like that well the pep pep the
private Equity Group was buying up bus
buying up business so that's what you
specialized in I mean I was so young
back then I couldn't say I specialized
in anything those roles when you're an
analyst too I think I left and I was an
associate you you're you're glorified
PowerPoint maker Excel spreadsheet taker
that's about it but working a lot but
working like crazy it's a universe of
please fixes and late nights and all you
really learn is the language of Finance
the language of money and hard work um
and then and the language of money is
really important for people to know I
mean you you guys teach this all day
long but um if you don't understand how
people talk about money you're never
going to make it you know it's just like
uh money is a cruel mistress if you
don't track her she'll leave you for
somebody that does and it's the same
thing with the language of money if you
can't speak to it it's not going to
speak back to you um and so that's what
I really learned at Goldman so let's
talk about the language of money because
you bring this up a lot your interview
does that re a certain vocabul that
certain viewers should know or is it
just the way that you speak with
confidence what is the language of money
and how can people learn it I think it
is actually vocabulary it's and it's not
that comprehensive but if you spent like
10 minutes a day on Investopedia you
could probably play this game pretty
easily like most people don't understand
Roi like what is your return on income
they don't actually understand basis
points which is just another way of
saying fees Finance has a separate
language because they want you to think
that making money is harder than it is
when you have money and so you give it
to them and they charge you a fee
instead of the other way around and so I
think money is a little bit like
medicine it's gate kept right because
there's a huge financial incentive for
you to put your trust in them as opposed
to yourself and so I do think people
need to learn the language of money in
some some way shape or form that's
really interesting so you're saying that
the people that know the language the
people that make money with your money
just kind of created this exclusive
language so then it can seem like
there's a higher you're entry and you
can't do it yourself I think it's yep I
think that's exactly right why would you
ever leave that job at Golden Sachs it
seems like making that much money in
your early 20s if you just grind that
out yeah for like 15 years you're set
for life like why risk it why even leave
gr you sound like my mom my Latina mom I
think she cried when I left the firm um
she cried I don't know she hates when I
do these interviews and say stuff like
that but she was not happy
um listen
um I do think that you have to keep I
think you should stay at a job for
exactly this long amount of time that
you are still continuously learning with
an upside to continue earning and in the
beginning of your career you should
optimize for learning who cares what you
make in your first couple of jobs
because you don't know anything and so
you aren't going to be able to earn
enough you just have to optimize for
learning at some point you want to have
the learning equal the earning but the
second that you stop learning on a job
is the second I think you should first
tell your boss about it and then second
leave
and that's what I do with our employees
too it's like you if you are stopping
learning at any point please tell me
come to me and let's figure out a plan
for you to continue to learn because um
I stopped learning at Goldman I felt
like I had learned what I needed to
learn in this this one uh individual
segment and uh and I needed to move on
and if I couldn't find a way to move on
or move up then I was going to move out
and um and that was that was basically
the idea and I really wanted to do this
job so there are like a couple different
types of of jobs and Finance in in
Investment Banking and private Equity
asset management and I wanted to do the
type that was in the field like I wanted
to go do due diligence on the companies
individually I wanted to do Partnerships
with big institutions like I wanted to
give the PowerPoint presentations I
didn't want to be the one creating them
and uh and Goldman you know rightly so
was like you're five take it easy like
give it a few more years and I was like
No And so that's why I went to State
Street where I could go do that and play
hand toand combat did they match the
offer that you had with Goldman did you
tell them I was making a few hundred
grand like just match this plus a little
more H I don't remember um I do
remember I've always been interested in
upside so like where can I go I don't
care that much about what you start me
with I don't want you to limit the top
and so at that time the job that I went
after was I wanted to head a Latin
American Investment Group for them
because they didn't have one and they
were like No And instead I interviewed
with 452 people and finally settled on
uh this idea of uh I invested cash for
them it was the cash management group at
the time and ran a segment of the
business doing that and so um my only
thing that I really wanted to do was be
paid dollar for dollar for everything
that I brought in and keep learning and
I didn't understand anything about this
side of the business so that's why I
went there you said you were interviewed
by 452 people not literally it was
probably more like I when I interviewed
for State Street I flew to Boston I flew
to San Francisco those are two marent
offices uh I met a guy in Dallas for it
and at each location I think I met three
to five people
because just had to clarify yeah yeah
not literally 4 152 um because I wanted
a job that didn't quite exist which um
is a common a Common Thread and
something people don't do enough you
know like how thrilled would you be if
somebody came to you and they were
like um I've watched your business for
some time I think you guys make money by
doing advertising and sponsorships
largely I imagine that that's tough and
that you don't have enough people to do
it and if I was able to bring you
aligned advertisers and sponsors for
your channel uh and you approved them
and liked them could I come on board and
be one of your distribution partners for
it I'll work for you and you only have
to pay me a percentage of the stuff that
I bring in you guys would probably
say yes
yeah and and so that's what I did um and
I think more people should do that
continuously they wait for a job opening
to come up as opposed to saying I'm
actually going to I'm not going to
sniper I'm not going to rifle shot what
I want I'm going to sniper shot I want
to work at the ice coffee hour and so
because I want to work for these two and
I want to optimize for learning let me
create a position that is so
irresistible to them that they can't say
no to me and if I do that then I bet I
get to learn I bet I get to earn and
they're going to have a lot of respect
for me because in a world of you know
rule takers uh I'm going to be a rule
maker and and game recognizes game at
what point did you buy your first
business when did you realize that like
State Street was not enough that you
couldn't satisfy the entrepreneurial bug
by doing these jobs well the first
business I bought was actually it was
called selling South back in the day and
it was a Consulting business basically
across the US Mexico border so that was
like State Street days and um and that
business did okay uh how do you just buy
a
business did you did you know of them
ahead of time like you I was so they
were trying to sell me services this is
so I call this one of the best ways I
like to buy businesses is called the
personal pnl review which basically
means you look at the things that you
spend money on and you look at the
things that you um that you get money
from so I was in a business at this
point but if you work in a job you could
say the same thing and you figure out
are any of these businesses small enough
where I could actually get to the owner
and if I can get to the owner can I talk
to them does it seems like a business
that I'd want to buy and if so can I
have the conversation about buying so in
this instance the guy wanted to sell me
consulting services to uh Latin America
as part of our business and it was a
little you know kind of tiny little
operation and I started talking to them
and I was like God this guy's terrible
at sales and yet he's pretty smart and
this is actually a pretty good business
model it's a productized service why
don't I why don't I negotiate with him
and say you're not very good at sales
doesn't seem like you like sales I like
sales and bringing people into
businesses what if I buy part of your
business and uh and I only do it for the
amount of Revenue that I can add
additionally add to your business and if
that works out maybe I buy the business
out right so that was of the first
transactions and how much was
it 150 170 something like that not a big
transaction but not all at once I kind
of got to test the waters first you get
a loan for something like that or you no
at the time I had enough money but if I
did it again uh like now I'm very greedy
with personal capital I think anytime
you can you want to play with other
people's money instead of your own
because you just decrease the risk and
money is way more abundant than anybody
ever thinks and so there's money all
around all the time and it's there for
the taking it's just you have to speak
the language and you have to be able to
give the ask um and most of us weren't
taught that you know we were taught
budgeting and saving and don't have your
Starbucks and I don't believe in
any of that although I have a lot of
respect for the people that help people
get out of debt because that is actually
very hard once you've dug a hole but uh
if you want to have upside earnings you
can't you can't save your way to your
first 10 million like this is not going
to work and I like playing the upside
game because I've never really liked
budgeting I don't I don't I want to be
able to spend what I want to spend when
I want to spend it and the only way to
do that is make a lot of money so that
was the first deal and then I did
another couple deals then I did a
laundromat deal that was the first one
that I talked about on the internet
basically yeah what happened with the
laundromat why laundromats I looked into
laundromats like 2014 2013 I decided
against it because of how Capital
intensive it was and all the overhead
and how competitive it was I had no idea
that laundromats are so territorial like
if you open up a laundromat within a
certain location of another established
one it's like really frowned upon in the
industry and the established laundromat
could actually undercut the other one
the new one and they'll run it a loss
just to run the other one out of
business if they're like really
successful I've just read these crazy
stories online yeah I mean I talk about
uh gateway drug businesses so like what
are the businesses that are simple to
understand that uh don't take a ton of
capital that cash flow and I like
starting with those just like you would
any gateway drug because they're easy
there's simple and once you can
understand that business then you can
stair step your way to higher levels of
the game and not all businesses are
created equal right um and not all
business models are created equal and we
weren't taught that you know that's
something I learned probably doing you
know at Goldman and looking at all these
businesses is you see like why does this
business that does a million dollars a
year and this business that does a
million dollars a year why is this one
worth five million and this one is worth
$250,000 they both make the same amount
of money and like those are the classes
we were never taught right things like
valuations and multiples and um you know
and what is what is eida a first profit
and and how about thinking about the
value of different types of iida and so
um I bought laundromats because I had a
guy uh I always start with who as
opposed to how and I had a laundromat
guy and so how do you just have a
laundromat guy he I think you should try
to be a collector of humans and so um I
collect competency wherever person who
leaves bodies behind that's exactly yeah
no I actually did the I like to do the
opposite of that like that person funny
story actually that person who took the
job that I was supposed to get at
Vanguard back in the day instead is a
dear friend of mine to this day her
name's April reppy shout out April and
uh she ended up becoming my number two
at the Latin America investment business
that I built and so um you know when I
see a human that is competent uh you
guys know this how many people do you
meet how about this game you go into a
business how many times you go into a
business and go why do they do it this
way what I'm in this dut shop and they
could sell me a coffee with this but
they don't the line is out the window
why don't they hire two more people
there's like a register there there's a
register there wait a second they don't
have a subscription model over here like
once you see it you see that
incompetence is all around it's the
status quo most people don't want to
work that hard and most people don't
want to think that critically and so
when you see competence when you see
somebody who's good and loves the game I
just try to keep them in my circle and
so with this individual I met him back
in the day and his name was Mike and um
he was running uh another laundr mat but
it was smaller and I was like if you run
one and it's kind of by this couldn't
you run two and I'm running a business
at the time but if I fund it for you
could couldn't you run it for me
theoretically he was like yes but why
would I and I was like oh it's this
thing called equity and I give you a
portion of it and um so that's how I
started that business and then I grew to
other laundr mats but I wouldn't
recommend everybody go out and buy a
laundr mat it's just where I started
what how much did you make from that
like what was involved in in running
that yeah well not much for me
um I try to have operators that run
buses that I don't have any expertise in
I run three buses right now which is
contan thinking contan thinking capital
and our hold Co so the one where we keep
our small businesses um but back then
you wouldn't want me running a
laundromat uh that would not have been
good for anybody and so Mike ran it but
I did the bookkeeping and I made sure
that I understood how our banking was
set up and our taxes filed and all that
um and when we first did that business
we made something like 667,000 in profit
when we bought the business and then I
think we got it up to 8090
$100,000 and how much was the laundromat
uh the laundromat that we bought was
about 100K and then eventually you got
up to $100,000 a year in profit
yeah only 100K CU usually these
laundromats are selling for like 2 to 5x
what you would make in profit well
couple things to think about a business
is really only worth what somebody will
pay for it right and so so a job of
running a laundromat for $60,000 $67,000
a year is actually not that it's not
that highly sought after of a job right
and so that's a very it's it's what's
called a micro level deal it's a very
tiny deal and so the reason why I could
buy that laundr mat is nobody else
wanted it he it been listed for a long
time there was no additional market for
it and nobody wanted a job for $67,000 a
year running this laundromat and you
know the books are a mess or they don't
even really have books it's an unbank
deal meaning you can't get debt for it
and so there's all these reasons why
businesses never sell but usually the
reasons are they don't make enough money
nobody wants the business the books are
really messy and um you know they're not
big enough for an institution or a
strategic to come in and buy it so
that's actually really really normal and
if you were to look at the numbers it's
really funny because people go one or
two ways on this deal they go no bucking
way that deal is so good who would sell
it for that and then the other side they
go that's a terrible deal why would you
do it and there's like no in between but
uh I don't actually believe in good or
bad deals I think it's only whether it's
a good or bad deal for you and that one
I was like I could lose 100K and i' like
it wouldn't bankrupt me and so I'm going
to learn on this deal I'm going to learn
with this guy and it's I felt like that
was an okay Bet to take at that time and
how'd you split it between you and the
operator I think he got I think he got
like 30 or 40% and I got 60 or 70 but I
paid him a salary so what he got
whatever the salary was and then he got
whatever percentage of the profits it
was which is typic how I do deals so I
want to get really granular on that
first deal because for most people
watching this that want to get involved
in their first business or by their
first business that I feel like is the
hardest barrier to surpass deal your
very first deal you had a connection
with this consulting firm that brings
people across the border is what selling
self yes yeah yeah yeah so how were you
this is just like
randomly yes so um how this happens is
right now we think about the people that
we spend money on right so if you think
about your podcast production C team or
the people who do video editing if it's
outsourced or could be even your agent
who has you know a 20% commission that
you pay you just kind of pay it right
you just pay it maybe you try to
negotiate down the rate that's first
level acquisition thinking which is you
know I already pay this person can I
negotiate it down or find somebody who's
less second level is you go huh I
actually really like working with this
person they're good at their job um what
if I just owned a portion of their
company instead and that's a huge unlock
for people the second that you guys
start thinking that way it'll happen to
you guys too now all of a sudden you'll
say I will never start a company again
because I get an unfair Advantage by
taking a look at a company that already
exists getting to know the owner and if
I'd want to do a deal with them and then
I can just decide what I want to own a
portion or all of this business one way
or the other and so that's what happened
with that guy I was like huh this is an
interesting business you're charging me
a lot for this I like what you're
providing what if I just own part of it
and what do the numbers look like after
you bought it I don't remember the exact
numbers on that but um um was it well
worth it and probably not you know that
was my very first deal so I think you
know we're talking maybe you're making
50 60
$7,000 at the time that was like you
know 12 years ago something like that so
that wouldn't have been worth it for me
at the time in a total monetary
perspective but I think like stair
stepping your way into deals is okay
it's okay for your first deal to not be
huge and replace your entire salary
because you're kind of learning the
first business you buy will never be the
last business that you own I don't think
if you do it right and so kind of
depends on what you mean by is it worth
it you know it was worth it from a
learning perspective which is what I
always go to first right and it wasn't
an insignificant amount of money and if
you had maybe three or four of these
then it would have actually been a big
piece of the pie right yeah and that one
I actually ended up having to sell out
of and shut down because my firm saw it
as a conflict of interest State Street
didn't like me having two businesses
because I was in finance so could that
of business have become a Million Dollar
Plus business yeah I think so I just was
too much of a wuss to leave my job at
the time so how many businesses did you
buy until you had to step down from
State Street well I didn't step down
from State Street I just went to a new a
new job so instead of selling them I
said oh you know I'm going to pass this
off this is now a passive investment
when you're in finance you have to
typically any business it could be a
conflict of interest you have to
disclose it because we're securi
licensed and so you know imagine trying
to tell your boss or having to tell your
boss every time you buy a single family
home you know at some point your boss is
like what the Ram you own like 52
of them and you work for me boss is just
like kind of get this resistance to that
so how many businesses did you buy until
you change positions a lot probably
probably 10 to 15 oh oh at State Street
yes no for your own personal portfol I
think one one and then that had conflict
of interest with State Street and then
you had to find a new job yeah exactly
yeah then I went to First Trust where
they were cool with it then I bought a
lot of businesses at First Trust over
the years um and then uh eventually six
years after I was at First Trust I went
to another company and at that company I
became a partner cuz I bought in that
was a company called at the time that
was Cresco Capital Partners they s
renamed and then I bought a lot more
companies why are you buying so many
companies doesn't it seem like a bit of
a hassle why not just buy like two of
them and run those really well yeah why
10 15 well one I come from private
Equity so it actually makes sense right
what do private Equity Funds do they buy
lots of businesses so you're always a
reflection of what you've been
surrounded with and so most people who
are entrepreneurs are like what is wrong
with you why would you own 15 or 20
companies
and then if you've been in private
Equity you're like oh of course and then
you wrap some layers around it you add
some management fees you know you have a
CIO at the top it's a typical fund
strategy so that was just you know two
ways to to play this game one is private
Equity Fund where you have a lot of
different companies totally different
sectors typically um another way to play
it is a holding company where you don't
have investors you just do it by
yourself that's typically what I do
right now and then I guess a third way
to do it is uh you have one company and
you add on a bunch of Acquisitions to
that one company none of them are better
yeah than the other did you have a
segment of businesses that you would
invest in although before we go into
that does your hair look like this take
a look on screen if you're listening to
this does it look like this and do you
want it to look like this well that's a
possibility thanks to our sponsor Hy
hims is a 100% online platform that is
changing men's Healthcare with hims you
can find the right treatment to regrow
your hair back in as little as 3 to 6
months hims is a 100% online platform
that helps you regrow your hair in as
little as 3 to 6 months uses do trusted
minoxidil and finasteride which we
discussed in detail in the more plates
more dates podcast just a few weeks ago
and if you don't want to take a pill him
also provides serums sprays and chewable
options and if you're prescribed your
medication will be shipped directly to
you for free with discret packaging they
also treat erectile dysfunction and
weight loss if that's what you're
struggling with no insurance is needed
you'll pay one low price for all of your
treatments online visits ongoing
shipments and provider messaging and
you're able to track everything on the
hyms app so if your hair is receding
thinning at the crown or just thinning
in general you can start your free
online visit today at
hims.com once again if you want a free
online visit check out hms.com to get
personalized treatment options or click
the link Down Below in the description
today disclaimer prescriptions require
online consultation with the healthare
Prov will deter appropriate restrictions
apply c.com for details important safy
information subscription required price
are based on product and subscription
plan and now that said let's get back to
the episode did you have a segment of
businesses that you would invest in and
what was that cuz it seems like you know
laundromats are very like a kind of like
blue collar
services so do you have a preference of
what you specialized in well right now
at contr and thinking Capital we have
sort of two types of businesses we buy
we have our media accelerated businesses
which I think anybody who is online who
is a Creator you are absolutely crazy if
you are just taking advertising and
sponsorship dollars you should be owning
a portion of the companies that you talk
about the most think about it this way
if you guys didn't know this I was blown
away when I saw these numbers Venture
capitalists who fund startups right they
give a dollar to a startup 40 cents of
every dollar goes immediately to what
client acquisition which is just ads it
goes to Facebook it goes to Instagram it
goes to Google 40 cents of every dollar
that a VC gives them goes to
distribution so if that's the case you
should know if you are the distribution
what are you worth about 40% of
a company now they're not going to
always give you that but you definitely
shouldn't be taking a one-time purchase
as part of your your fee and so um we
have one segment of the business that's
media accelerated company so we have
companies like viral cuts that does
video production um for us and uh and
they do video production for a ton of
other people then I own a portion of
that company and then we have a company
called approachment that's sort of the
same it's a chat box that helps
accelerate how fast you respond to leads
if you have a company so that's the
biggest denominator of success in a
small business is do you respond faster
or do you respond faster whoever
responds faster wins that's like the
easiest rule of business in nobody pays
attention to yeah it's interesting cuz I
tried that strategy I heard of that uh
four or five years ago why would you
just take sponsorship just ask for
Equity instead and I found a weird
correlation between anytime I ask for
Equity instead of payment the good
companies would say no they know what
they're worth they have no interest in
giving up any amount of equity y but the
bad companies would say oh yeah
absolutely this is great and just in my
mind I now get instantly suspicious
you're giving that back why if you
really believed in yourself why on Earth
would you give up equity and it seems to
remain true the companies that are
really good want to keep it to
themselves well it depends what your
offer is so if you're going to go and
have I don't know 50 sponsorships a year
for ice coffee hour you don't want to go
and get 50 little bets 50 little hail
marries that you're going to throw with
trying to get Equity what do you
actually want to do you want to talk to
150 companies and you want to have four
companies that you have sponsor
throughout the year and by sponsorship I
don't don't just take Equity you take
something called Distributing equity and
distributing Equity is basically just
for all of your listeners Distributing
Equity means yes you're going to you're
going to give me a percentage of your
company so if one day you sell I win
awesome but for every percent equity you
give me I want you to give me a
distribution either of profit or Revenue
sharing depending on what you can
negotiate um so that I get paid to wait
because I'm being I'm doing a lot of
work this work over here is expensive
and so I want to get paid to wait and so
because of that you need to do lot more
due diligence to figure out which
companies you're going to do and then
you pick a few companies um but yeah
it's true I mean Spotify is going to go
that's cute Graham like no of course you
can't have any equity in our company um
but if you have um vendors that you've
been working with that you already know
they're great and uh then you then you
probably can't get equity in that
company you know or if you try friends
products and you like those products you
can probably get equity in that company
too okay would love equity and new new
tonic by the way chis these are so good
which deal would you say in the first
few years really made the biggest impact
where you're like okay this is 100%
something that I can 100% do it's going
to make me a bunch of money and this is
where my future is the first deal I
think the laundr matat was the first
deal where I realized oh I can buy a
business and I cannot drive that
business you know the the Consulting
businesses and some of the vendors I it
was basically a a Sweat Equity deal
right it was I'm gonna buy a portion of
this but I will do this thing for you
and the laundry Mount was the first one
where I was like I'm not going to do
anything I'm just going to invest in
this and then you're going to run this
business and so that one even though
it's not the biggest deal I've ever done
it was the most impactful because I saw
what could happen if you hire great
people to work for you and I think
that's the real unlock for wealth that
nobody wants to talk about it's it's can
you attract other people to your dream
is your dream big enough where other
people want to stand under the umbrella
of it and that was the first company
that I sold a dream to somebody what is
seem like blue collar work is really
underappreciated it's not sexy I mean
there's something called the S Hurst
Matrix and the S Hurst Matrix basically
shows that the um more boring a company
is and the more simple a company is the
higher likelihood it has to succeed in
cash flow over the long term and the
lower likelihood it has to attract
talent and individuals and so you know
we humans are attracted to flashy sexy
things for whatever reason and I think
we have also been sold a Dream by
Venture capitalists uh for a long time
that the best way to make real wealth is
to do a startup and take their money and
then go build it and um and so I think
it's been sort of systematically beaten
into us that we want to be on the cover
of Forbes with some flashy new social
media site and that's what all the
movies get made of like there's no
movies about plumbers who make tens of
millions of dollars unless they look
like idiots you know and so um I don't
know that there's some you know cobal of
elite trying to teach us that this the
service industry is bad I just think
that it has had really bad PR um because
you know over time how do most people
get on the The Fortune 100 or the Forbes
100 wealthiest people list if you look
at that list it's like it's it's
basically three categories it's Finance
people whether it's private Equity you
know asset managers investors it's
inherited money and it's people who have
built businesses and the people who have
built businesses category is really
split more like 64 to industries that
wouldn't seem sexy agriculture uh energy
um grocery as opposed to like the number
of tech billionaires on there it's just
that Elon Musk is a lot sexier of a
story than the CEO of Walmart at least
that's my thought I think there's a lot
of businesses out there that are in the1
to1 million range that are just they fly
under the radar but it's a lot of like
you said like the plumbers electricians
people running small
operations um there's some businesses
that I've that I've seen on YouTube
where they go into it like one dude was
making millions of dollars a year
putting up fences and then one I think
was $600 million a year in Revenue
building basements those are such cool
businesses I think it was either uplip
or Noah Kagan yeah one of the two oh
you're right I think it was I think it
was Noah did the uh basement he did
basements yeah well I think it's having
a little bit of a Resurgence you know um
actually our mutual buddy Chris
Williamson does talk about how you know
that a market is saturated once it's
becoming memed right and so like every
every movement goes through sort of like
three phases and the first phase is
Discovery right it's like the first
Spider-Man movie right like this is cool
I've never seen anything like it and
then you get to the peak of the movement
which is like holy crap there's you know
Spider-Man 12 and 57 and then you get
into the meme of Spider-Man which is
like Thor rag a rock where the hero is
no longer cool he's kind of a joke right
and so like each movement kind of goes
through this set of stages and um and I
think you know a movement is sort of at
its peak tail when they started to make
fun of it and so Silicon Valley and and
VC is definitely there and I think
people also I think we're we're at Peak
Interest in boring businesses right now
and it's just starting to get to a place
where people are like you know some
jokes about Wharton and harvor grads you
know all flocking to want to go buy a
laundromat right and so we're we're like
coming into that tale where it's going
to become I think a little bit of a meme
but what I'm really curious about is
what happens over the next 10 or 15
years with all of these businesses
transitioning you know I tend to think I
don't know if Hollywood will ever catch
on but I tend to think there's going to
be a lot more people interested just
like they are now in like the tradwife
movement and in the like you know I want
to go live on a farm movement I don't
want to be in the city anymore movement
I want to make my own sourdough bread
movement I think that same thing wants
to make sourdough everybody sour is
having a moment why sourdough yeah it's
it's it's the Kardashian uh whipsaw
effect I think it's you know it's the
same thing it's we for so long have been
told if you think about it like people
ask me why are women this way when I
come on a podcast you seem strong and
like you have a good head on your
shoulders what's what's wrong with women
and I always kind of giggle I'm like
think about it this way when we were
young we were told um you know you're
going to need to carve up your face with
plastic surgery you're going to have to
have lips that look like a platypus
you're going to have to have a waist
like this an ass like this you're going
to want to go you know wear all of these
like kind of scandalous clothes then we
were told now in these days OIC body get
really skinny get rid of the BBL now
we're going for like a more natural look
you know our our the role models that we
gave young kids was the Kardashians now
maybe it's not and so I think there's
just this whipsaw that happens in
society and so anytime that we have
something so egregious as like body
dysmorphia and massive amount of plastic
surgery we're going to have the opposite
movement which is going to be no makeup
Tallow butter no shoes sundresses so
growing up obviously as a guy uh and not
having a sister or anything like that I
feel like this is still very honestly
kind of new to me all of like this
pressure and everything that like who is
instilling this pressure in these young
girls that they need to have these sorts
of bodies is it like the news or is it
like like who who is it well I think
it's uh social media has been a catalyst
of this for all of us it's just now
coming around for you guys I think you
know now it's going to be a big movement
for men where that's why we had the
Andrew Tates the alpha movements all of
that because we had this push back to
you know what should a man be one way or
the other and it was like now men should
you know first it was men should cry uh
men should be soft huge me too movement
and then it was that I don't want
to cry I'm going to be tough I'm going
to drive Lambos I'm going to do whatever
and then I think the next St stage of
man is going to be something else Chris
Williamson might be a product of it the
Phil the philosopher king you know
this yeah right the the I am strong but
I am also thoughtful and soft and not a
boy you know and so we kind of see
these movements go and you know liver
King out Chris Williamson in um and uh
he's gonna love that comparison but with
with women just the same with men it's
just it's social mirrors we're all a
programming of the things that surround
us with mtic desire 101 human beings are
programmed to want the things that we
see other people having and um you know
Joe despenza talks about this a lot that
we kind of become the things that other
people are because we don't actually
know innately what we want individually
and so young girls just saw filters and
makeup and you know XYZ that they needed
to have on and thought that that was
normal how did that affect you um I've
always been a bit of a tomboy so the
only thing that affects me on that is
thinking about
you know actually mine's different the
weird part for women which nobody's
going to care about on YouTube I think
is like once you start aging as a woman
it's a really weird phenomenon so like
I'm in my later 30s and starting to
think about what is it what does it look
like to be like a middle-aged woman you
know there's like a stereotype to what
is middle-aged and so that part's going
to be interesting I think and tough
especially when you're watching it on
camera all the time you know like what
does my face look like you know what
about when wrinkles common bags is that
you or is it because you're getting
comments or feedback telling you this or
is this your head thank God but no I
think about it I try to forward think
about what are the things that will I
try to think about going forward where
could I fall into societal traps right
and I think that's one of them and
that's why people's face can end up
getting crazy looking at a certain point
if you have money because you worry
about that how do you deal with some of
those societal pressures that they put
on you let's say to why aren't why don't
you have kids yet and all of these
things why do you focus so much on your
career I can't remember who said it but
uh there's a line I love which is in
order to be successful you have to have
someone who loves you greatly and you
have to have a great enemy and I always
liked this idea the great enemy is
somebody to overcome it's David versus
Goliath it's um this big huge goal in
front of you and someone who loves you
unconditionally is you know the mother
figure the partner figure Etc and so a
lot of where I get my grounding is those
closest to me you know I have an
incredible husband and I think
partnership is probably the foundation
for success for me it's a lot easier to
strive far when you have somebody that
you can really rely on and you're a team
together so I treasure that and then the
other side of the coin is you know you
build up an armor of nose I think being
online you guys have gone through it um
you get a little bit desensitized to the
amount of negative commentary that comes
to you because you get so much of it um
and so I think it's a constant game but
I did I was reading somewhere that human
brains are wired to ignore positive
feedback and compliments and to focus on
uh detractions or um not compliments and
it makes sense so basically what is Fame
then that means that Fame is essentially
a few periodic moments of bliss in the
form of a lot of compliments a lot of
attention uh largely predominated by uh
negative commentary because you just get
so much of it if you open your feedback
loop and you don't remember the positive
but you remember the negative and you
start to get kind of famous what are you
what's going to happen you're going to
remember more of the negative commentary
because you just get so much of it and
so I try to think about that
philosophically when I post online or
when somebody doesn't like something
that I do that just this is my lizard
brain and that's how it's going to
function what do you think of gender
roles and do you think they might exist
for a reason I mean some some parts of
it yeah I think Anatomy is real and uh I
do not want my husband to be exactly
equal to to me that is a personal
preference I think anybody can be
whatever they want in their
relationships but for me I like my man
and my husband strong and able to take
care of me and be a protector and
simultaneously he's an incredible cook
so he does most of the cooking and um
and so you know and I've made a lot of
money for a lot of a lot of years and he
was an ay seal and they don't pay very
well and so we have that flipped Dynamic
now it's interesting cuz I'm going to go
on another podcast here which you guys
know today that we'll probably talk
about some of this and has very
traditional gender roles well we could
just say it cuz you know Brad Lee right
you know Brad is like I'm the man and
when I what did he tell the other day
that I'm going to give him about
today he's like uh he's like I have a
magical carpet and he's like on this
magical carpet when I set something down
on it disappears you know how is my wife
picks it up because I make the money and
she picks up the stuff and you know he's
actually a lovely guy um but I was
joking with him that like that would
work for me but that doesn't mean that
you know his is wrong and mine is Right
which is my biggest beef with the
internet these days I'm like let's yeah
let's have strength spaced relationships
which is what my husband and I have I'm
good at this he's good at that and we
allow each other to be great at the
things that we're great at and we don't
feel badly for it and we do only what
works for us and everybody else
yeah are there any difficulties having
an income inequality between you and
your husband I think uh if if he ever
optimized for earnings as his definition
it would be tough I think men who think
that the only way that they are
masculine is by the amount of money that
they earn that would be difficult my
husband never optimized for that he
optimized for becoming a warrior an
incredibly strong individual both
mentally and physically um and living by
code in a world that was codeless and so
for him you know if he wanted to
optimize for money he could do just as
well that just wasn't his code and so I
think that's also really beautiful in a
relationship to determine what's your
code familially and individually like if
your wife's code is that I am the
protector of our children and I am their
Shepherd to becoming incredible humans
that's a beautiful code and if the
husbands is that I am the protector of
the family financially and I'm going to
be the one that determines our ability
to live within a society that's based on
money that's a beautiful code and so um
it really just depends on you finding
the person that aligns with your code in
my opinion how did you meet him though
my father actually good old arranged
marriage um the uh the my we both grew
up in Arizona and um Chris and my father
used to hunt together and so I've known
Chris since I was like 10 years old
we've known each other for whatever I
don't want to give away my age but a
long time and uh he uh used to hunt with
my dad for years and years and years and
after I got divorced you know my dad
wanted me to find a nice guy again and
so uh introduced me to Chris and there's
an old old um I should have brought one
for you guys I will next time there's
there's a um there's a tradition inside
the teams which is what they call the
Navy Seals where when somebody does
something really special for you you
gift them both a knife and a coin and
the knife is a reminder of you know the
fact that we all are these these
Warriors if we choose to be and the coin
is something they're supposed to give
back to you which is um it started from
the challenge coin uh which was started
during World War II challenge coins were
given by pilots for achieving certain
things and so they give the coin back to
you and so he did that for my father and
my father thought it was really cool and
so I actually slipped into his DMS and
said thank you for doing that and we
struck up a relationship um I was living
in Chile at the time he was unemployment
and then it's been uh been Off to the
Races ever since then was there ever any
power dynamic because you made so much
more money no I
remember I remember exactly like the
moment that I knew that Chris was going
to be the one for me and that was I was
uh struggling with my career I was going
to get pushed out of a firm essentially
and um and I didn't know what I was
going to do and I had to find myself
most of my Life by What My Title was
what I earned and you know who I was you
know like do you know who I am by the
work that I do and that's how I defined
myself and I was rudderless because I
had built this really big business for
somebody and they were saying that I
wasn't good enough and um and I remember
Chris came down to this like nice hotel
we were at and I told him like Hey you
know I might have to leave this firm
because I don't think I can align with
what they're doing and I and I think I'm
going to get pushed out and he was
making I don't know what you make when
you're an Navy SEAL at that amount but
not very much in comparison and he just
like looked at me and he was like I got
you like I'll take care of all the
expenses you can move in with me it
doesn't matter what you make I got you
and I remember kind of chuckling at
first cuz I was like you don't know how
much I spend so like what are you
signing up for but um but it was that
moment where he did not care he was like
we will live in you know we'll we'll
live in a tent together like it doesn't
matter and like we've been through
harder things than this he's like and he
often will look at me and he did that
day and he was like well is anybody
going to die and I was like no and he's
like then I think we can figure it out
and so now a lot of times we say to each
other well is anybody going to die when
something happens if nobody's going to
die we'll probably figure it out and so
never a power dynamic because he sees
the world differently good could you
that on Graham time I'm trying to make a
left turn and he's like no Jack don't go
down that street it's going to take a
long time we're going to wait at the
light anyone going to die going to die
going to use that everything everything
I thank you for giving me that video 10
out of 10 we got to fix it but is anyone
gonna die there we go we don't know it's
funny it's a good line I love talking
about dating hopefully we'll get back
into that but feel like we need to
finish up this timeline okay so you
start acquiring all of these businesses
your first like real confidence boost
was was the laundromat how did it evolve
from there until now where it's just I
mean I don't even know what to call it
now it like it reminds me of very horos
esque thing just because we're so
familiar with him that's why I relate it
to that uh where it's kind of like your
own family office in a sense yeah well
that's what it was for a long time so um
Alex and Laya dear friends I respect
them immensely um it started as a family
office uh which was just me and my chief
investment officer while I was still
working at a few firms and then common
story you know I was I kind of got
pushed out again of another firm like I
really had this belief that nobody
believed at the time that that the way
we raised money and did deals was going
to be on the internet in the future and
that we would no longer go and do steak
dinners and Road shows which is the way
that stuff got done in the past it was
going to be the internet we were going
to drive deals to us from the internet
we were going to drive investors to us
from the internet my partners disagreed
and so they said two options like you
know you go do your own thing uh or you
do it you know our way because there
were four of us and they disagree all
three of them disagree with me and I
said well I can't do it your way and so
um so I finished up the last fund with
them and and we're still friends to this
day and I went and said I'm going to
start talking about what I do online and
um that was in
2020 and I had already had this
portfolio of businesses and I started
getting this inkling that people thought
it was interesting because I spoke on a
few panels randomly in the industry and
people were like what you buy businesses
and anybody can do it and how does that
work and I'm like oh interesting and so
because I noticed that we just started
talking about on the internet and that's
when contan thinking was born during the
pandemic when I couldn't run around and
do po uh Road shows anyway and so um
from there we just grew the business I
started to realize wait a second we can
have media be our Salesforce so
typically you have when you have a
private Equity Firm uh you have like two
types of sales teams you can call them
you have somebody that brings in your
deals and you have somebody that brings
in your investors right so twofold
distribution and um and I was like I
think we can take both of those and we
can change from humans into content and
that was my bet it turned out to be
right and so we started telling people
hey we buy businesses and because of
that I started getting more businesses
and then I started saying hey we do
individual deals and so then we have a
few deals that we did spvs on with
individual investors and we brought in
some of my good friends now to this day
who are that now we don't take public
money anymore but um
and that turned into what I now call the
Main Street holding company which
started out as a glorified family office
and um I remember when I was first
talking to Alex and Lea and they were
thinking about Acquisitions you know we
were talking about it and I was like
I'll tell you what happens because
there's like a proven path for everybody
that does this and it's why it exists
the way that it exists you have Venture
Capital which is tiny little percentage
of equity in a company plus godp speed
good luck they don't really help you
right anybody who says they're value ad
they're really not very value ad it's
like tiny we'll take a tiny percent of
the company we'll invest in a thousand
of you and couple of you were
survive and we'll make all our money off
of that which is called modern portfolio
Theory then you've got over here private
Equity right which is like we're going
to have a lot fewer players but we're
going to own basically all of you and
anything that is in the middle I call
the tragedy of the commons and the
tragedy of the commons is when you own a
small percentage of companies but you
actually have to operate them too and
that's awful and so um what we did is we
we basically barbell it so now we have a
Venture Capital fund where we do what I
just talked about and we have our
private Equity holding company where we
own most of the underlying businesses
and that's what we do today so where's
most of the revenue coming from across
everything well the biggest segment of
Revenue is from the holding company so
the holding company is where we hold all
of our cash flowing businesses and all
the Investments that have just had a
long time to percolate because we've
been doing this for a decade plus um so
that's our biggest investment uh the
Venture Capital basically has no income
it's a smallish fund and that's all like
an AS Sy metric bet maybe on the upside
and then I guess you know over here at
the top you have contrarian thinking
which is the media company the media
company I sort of treat it like uh it's
almost not profitable because we take
all the money we make from education and
courses and we funnel it back into
Tanner Tanner's huge bonus um but our uh
our media company and so we use the
dollars that we get from education and
courses to get more followers and create
what I call a virtuous cycle and then
from that virtuous cycle we also get
deals and if we want to raise money we
could get investors so the holding
company that's where the $80 million a
year comes from yeah okay and then of
this holding company if we're getting a
little bit more granular let's say we
got a little pie okay Grand loves the
pie why can't we have a cake sure it's a
cake what kind of cake Graham uh velvet
ew are you kidding me yeah red velvet no
we're not doing r that I because you
hate it all right F PE lime pie oh
that's worse wrong with are you kidding
me say chocolate just say chocolate
chocolate chocolate okay so we got a
chocolate pie
okay chocolate cake all right chocolate
cake what do these slices look like I'm
sure that it's probably a few businesses
that do a bulk of the income and then
everything else is kind of just like
minuscule little Graham slices
yeah thanks what does it what does it
look like he doesn't eat much that's why
he doesn't eat much so in the Main
Street holding company uh there's
there's kind of those three types of
business I talked about so we have a
media accelerated businesses we have uh
real estate uh based businesses which
are things like mobile home parks um
property management companies Airbnb
businesses and then we have uh boring
businesses typically service or
professional based businesses and so of
those you know we have 25 businesses the
what do you want the percentage of
breakdown between the three types sure
yeah um let's see so in the media
accelerated businesses that's probably
our smallest slice that's what I want to
be our biggest slice it's our smallest
right now let's call it 10 or 15% and
those are like the viral Cuts thing and
yeah and we have we'll talk about this
in a second where I want to go but um
that's probably the smallest slice then
the next bigger slice would be the
boring service based businesses and then
the final slice would be the real estate
businesses which are probably more like
20 25% so what does that leave 60 60 65%
boring businesses what's the best
business for someone to buy what makes
the most money the best business to buy
is your unfair Advantage business which
is a super annoying answer except it's
true anybody who tells you like that's
why I don't like people on the internet
they go it should be Drop Shipping it
should be Amazon FBA it should be
laundromats no it shouldn't the there's
like 10 steps to buy in a business that
I talk about and the most important step
is step two which is what's called your
dealbox how you decide what you should
invest in individually and so everybody
wants the 30second answer which is you
should buy gy CU that's what horos does
um that's that's actually not right in
my opinion the right thing is you have
to go down this checklist of like the
Oracle of Deli said knowing yourself and
so once you know there's like basically
five key segments any business right
every business has marketing they have
operations they have product they
typically have uh like sales of some
component of it and they have Finance
right and every single one of us
typically has one or two skill sets of
those five things so you guys may be
great at sales and marketing maybe
you're not so good at operations and
finance and so what I really like to do
is have people think about what type of
business is best for you a business that
needs more sales a business that needs
better operations a business that needs
better product and to focus on the type
of business that needs that so that's my
long-winded answer to that and how do
you hire people and how do you look for
the a players a couple things with a
players in particular we have uh an idea
overall that we think a competent
Optimist is worth about six figures more
than a really brilliant pessimist and so
when I'm looking at a players one I want
optimists because optimists make money
and pessimists make the news and so we
obsess on this idea of optimism and one
of uh you know Tanner's quotes for this
year that was really good is it's our
our mantra for 2023 is like we're
optimistically discontent so we're
consistently slight upset with where
we're at but optimistic about where we
can go and that's what I want in the
people that we hire we have a list of
characteristics for a players that we
hire and a couple of them are things
like this the best predictor of future
behavior is past Behavior so we want a
history of winning I call this a wall of
metals so you don't actually want to bet
on somebody who has Bumble their
way through life today let them get a
few wins under their belt and then hire
them because there's something called uh
continual velocity right so the
likelihood of you continuing to move
quickly if you've moved quickly
historically is higher and that's the
same thing with humans we also want
Shepherds not sheep and so the best
hires are people where you go amazing
Graham We want to hire you who else
would you bring and if they go oh I
don't I don't know that means they're
not a leader okay and so you want to
find people who are already going to
bring your next couple of people super
super important and then you know the
last thing that I think is is really
important is obsessed people will always
beat interested people and so we hire
people who are obsessed with something
doesn't have to be what we're talking
about but I always talk to them about
like what is the thing that you can't
stop doing even if you tried like where
do you lose all sense of time uh when
was the last time uh you stayed up
almost all night working on something
because you chose to not because you had
to and I want to find the people who
have that what are the dangers with
hiring B players I found it so
interesting I think it was Tom Bilu
about how B players bring you down bring
down the whole team significantly a a
players bring everyone up so like what's
been your experience on that what's the
studies behind that yeah there's an
incredible study that basically shows
proximity to Performance so if I sit
next to Graham and Jake if you sit next
to an under oh I call you Jake Graham
and Jake Jack Graham and Joe um
and and you are chocolate cake and Jake
I'll remember that now you get that for
the red velvet comment and the key lime
pie it's going to give me all the hard
questions now like you do all the guests
okay so um if you sit next to an
underperformer at your company you are
about well let's actually flip the other
way because it'll build up the expense
suspense if you sit next to a high
performer at a company that high
performer on average will increase your
performance by
15% if you sit next to a low performer
at your company that low performer will
decrease your produc ity by about 30%
and so if you think about it this way
the people that you surround yourself
with well whatever energy that they
bring it's contagious and so for our
teams I obsess on this fact and we've
all felt it youve felt that person who
sat next to you who you're like God shut
up Marge like it's not always negative I
don't feel good at the end of these
conversations I don't feel like we're
we're progressing that is a real
phenomenon and now there's a lot of
studies Arthur Brooks has incredible
studies on the effect of Happiness as
Contagion on the effect of obesity as
Contagion on the effective divorce as
contagion and the same thing tends to be
true with performance if you surround
yourself with high performers you will
perform higher if you surround yourself
with low performers you will double your
underperformance and of course these are
laws of averages not individuals but
important to know the law that's really
interesting why is it that b players
have that big of an effect on people
like let's say I'm at the top I'm an a
player why would let's say Jack a b
player let's say Jake you're the b Play
Jake you're the b player I'm the a
player Jake is the B player why would
that impact me to that degree would it
just be a distraction would I just be
less motivated like does that really
have I like to think that I'm somewhat
like impenetrable that I have this thing
around me no matter what's going on like
I could still give it my all I can see
him doubting you on this I can see the
doubt on his face um okay so I have a
couple different theories and it's hard
to to terine um you know causation as
opposed to correlation but um in this
instance what I've seen is um your high
performers will be the ones that are
most annoyed by your low low performers
and so if you have really high
performers on a team and you you make
them babysit or you make them Step Up
for your low performers they won't stay
so on average they're going their
annoyance level is higher than anybody
else because they're these people are in
their way so when that happens one
fascinating you start to lose more High
performers what does that mean you start
to attract more underperformers which
means that then you have an effect that
ripples wider so that's one thing I've
noticed in our companies second is that
I do think we underestimate the impact
of distraction so there's a lot of
studies out on this and I'll probably
get the numbers incorrect but there's a
lot of studies that show the um the
negative consequences of uh task
switching right and that in effect you
think well you know I don't know Ram
just came in and bothered me for 30
seconds so that means I lost 30 seconds
well it doesn't actually mean that
because Jack might have to go really
deep back into his work by rereading
going backwards getting refocused
getting another cup of coffee that 30
seconds may actually have a 20-minute
effect on him and so even if you're
impenetrable none of us are impen
impenetrable to task switching and the
Ripple effects of it and so those are
the two things I see that's really
interesting you've talked also about
seeing behind the curve curtain could
you explain that behind the curtain
basically means two two things in my
mind when I was younger I thought that
the people who were successful were
something magical you know like they had
a different gear They Were Somehow wired
different and you guys have met a lot of
successful people and I'm sure what
you've probably noticed is maybe there's
a few things different but they're
wildly human that the people at the top
are just like the rest of us and once
you normalize that I think it's
something that it's hard to unsee ever
again like you see through the Matrix
you know and you realize that this
little guy is just standing on a stool
and like most people that stool was his
unfair advantage that he got to stand on
one way or the other you know the second
behind the curtain that I think I
noticed early on is how much the people
at the top work together so you know if
think about us the Ripple effects that
we have from I know you through XYZ you
also know me here we both know Chris
we've talked about Alex we've hit on you
you know some of the other media
companies we've worked with and behind
the curtain is a series of humans who
are all interconnected and so one of the
unfair advantages and hacks I think
people can do is like how can you break
not into individuals but into circles
because once you break into a behindth
curtain Circle you just move faster it's
like they're on an an elevator and
they're all together and you think that
they're sprinting up the stairs but
together actually it's a lot easier than
it is individually and so that's what I
mean by behind the curtain why do you
think people get so jealous at seeing
someone's success because I remember was
a kid like 16 years old you'd see this
young guy driving down in a Ferrari or
like a Lamborghini and I never
understood why someone would look at
that person think uh it must be daddy's
money it's spoiled I'd look at that and
think what is this person doing how did
he do that is he self-made is it if it's
family money what did his dad do to or
his parents why do people look at that
with envy and disgust yeah well I think
you're wired that way because you know
that curiosity is the biggest driver for
long-term cash flow you know the more
Curious you are the more cash you're
going to make the more Curious you are
the more you're going to win because
you're actively trying to find answers
non-stop um sadly I
think when you
win you become a reflection for
everybody else's non achievements and so
you took the the shot you risked the
failure you went for what if because you
know that only lasts for a moment
instead of why never which lasts for a
lifetime right and so I think for most
people it's sadly it's not about you
it's that when they see success they see
all the things that they should have
done but they never did and you know
there's an old adage which is basically
that that I found to be true in about
80% of humans 80% of humans want you to
be just slightly less successful than
them and the second that you go beyond
their success level there's envy and
there is a
decreasing um selfworth basically why
haven't I done that and so once you
realize you realize it's very painful I
mean Dand pondi who's a kind of like an
Indian Guru I listen to he has this
incredible uh thing he does and it's
called the tissue Challenge and
basically if you can imagine it like
this so imagine I have a a tissue in my
hand right here and I'm holding the
middle of it and on each of the corners
of the tissue is like your best friend
um a business partner your mom your
brother right right as you have more and
more success what do you do you make
yourself higher than them that's hard
for people again it's a negative
reflection of the things that they have
not accomplished and that you have for
most humans but eventually what happens
is you continue lifting the tissue if
they stay on it with you everybody lifts
right and so I think that we have this
unique ability if we are winning to pull
everybody else alongside us and the
people who stay on your tissue are the
ones who when they see the Ferrari they
go wow and instead of why what is your
advice for people who want to become
rich or want to Achieve Financial
Independence where do they even start
because in your case they could say well
yeah you had a sixf figure job you had
all the savings you're making a ton of
money I'm working 9 to5 I have no
savings I'm paycheck to paycheck how
does this apply to me yeah well I think
I think my path might be the easiest
path to millions that anybody's taken
which is came from nothing got my first
job for 37 ,000 a year and worked for a
bunch of other people for I don't know8
years climbing the ladder without a lot
of risk and so you know I was a public
school kid I didn't make a lot of money
out of college the only thing that's
different is that you just stop taking
no for an answer and um I am I didn't
have a brilliant idea to do early on I I
didn't have a cool business model I
thought that I should try you know I was
I was devoid of any way that I could see
to start my own business in fact I had
so little I had so little creativity
with it that I had to go and work for
other people and then I had to buy other
people's businesses right because I
didn't have the idea of how to start it
by myself it took me a long time to do
that and so I actually think the fastest
path for people that is generalizable
because a lot of advice is actually just
you telling people what you did because
it worked for you I think the best
advice for people that are young is
simply this idea of you learn you earn
then you invest then you compound and
that's it it's like how can you learn as
much as possible how can you continue to
increase your earnings how can you start
investing those earnings continuously
and how can you continue to Compound on
that and if you can learn that if you
can do that while not taking no for an
answer it's I think it's pretty hard to
to not succeed and in fact I mean look
at some of the people at the top who
came from absolutely nothing there's
there's a flavor for everybody in
America today and what about women
specifically it's not very often that we
get actually a woman on the show most of
the time they're guys and then same for
the viewers most of the viewers are guys
but for the women watching right now how
would they do it and then also on top of
that what are your thoughts since it's
in the news right now on Dei yeah well
let's start with Dei because that's a
fun one I think
Dei is really harmful
for members of the diversity and
inclusion group and the reason why I
think it's harmful is because you're
immediately labeling yourself as someone
who needs help as someone who is less
than as someone who is a victim in one
shape or form and um you know I remember
many times uh I would get speech
requests or I would get somebody asking
me to be on a board or something and
they would say we need a female CEO and
I just said no if you need a CEO we can
talk but if you want to speak to me only
because I have a vagina as opposed to a
penis that makes no sense in business
what's the difference the only time that
makes sense is if I'm trying to go for a
female audience particularly and and my
anatomy in some way is necessary for the
business to move forward but I actually
think it does us a huge disservice to
focus in this specific way now do I
think that there is a huge advantage to
be part of a powerful majority yes 100%
being part of a power powerful majority
is real in any situation um and so you
know I there were many times where I
felt like I got left out because I was a
woman um where I didn't you know just
and not even from a sexist perspective
from a very reasonable perspective like
you know if I was single and you know
you have your lovely fiance fiance here
and um you know I was texting you late
at night and we were only talking about
business stuff but then we were going to
go grab dinner she might be like it's a
little weird like why are you you know
don't do that respect what we have here
right and that's totally reasonable but
if most of the men at the top are you
know the ones in powerful positions if
uh Jack was you know texting you late at
night doing that she wouldn't you
wouldn't think anything of it and so
inherently there's like a little bit of
difference between the two and I think
we have to realize that does it feel or
have you gotten comments of people
saying like oh you are where you are
because of Dei because I wonder if now
that's like working against people like
you who have gotten to the position
you're in purely based off of Merit yeah
no I mostly get you know uh must be nice
having Daddy's trust fund or uh you know
did your husband make all the money or
um do you get pretty privilege ever
no I would say I would be like no like
like that comment yes absolutely PR for
ACH um I do tend to believe like
anything somebody says to me I try to
flip it to the perspective of how could
this help me as opposed to why is this
annoying you know and so I try to just
let that roll off but no the you know
what annoys me is that um I actually
this is maybe dumb I did not really
think that misogyny or sexism really
existed very much anymore in the us
before I got on the internet because my
best mentors were men like asexually
like you know not in any way shape or
form like that my I'm incredibly close
to my dad my brother I an incredible
husband most of my team is guys um and
so I have a lot of respect for the
opposite sex and I never really got it I
didn't think I got pushed back because
of that I thought there were in you know
some instances but we all have those you
know maybe I had an unfair Advantage
here and they didn't I'm easy to
remember you're not if everybody's name
is
Jack Jake Todd Chad you know like harder
right and so I I kind of thought it was
good but then I got on the internet and
I did find that man people are nuts on
the internet what are they saying like
for instance um you know must be nice
you were a secretary at Goldman Sachs
that one bothered me like I had a tweet
real go really really viral and uh and
and yeah like somebody you know and they
get rolling together you know and so
they're like yeah I bet you was a
secretary there and then you know then
I'm like I'm going to show them my u4
I'm going to show them my f I was like
Jesus Christ but then they're like oh I
bet you was flirting with someone there
that one I haven't really gotten but
only maybe from other women sure um I
think men kind of know that like deep
down in in men's gut like I don't know
how many times are you promoting to the
CEO of a company a woman that you slept
with like you're just not doing
it that's not a there's not really a way
to like sleep your way to the top maybe
unless you're in Hollywood like you're
just not going to do it because it's
money and the one thing we all know in
business is that people care more about
money than anything else you can't
really sleep your way to the top there
politics maybe where money doesn't
matter Hollywood maybe where there's a
diamond dozen uh girls and a lot of
people with Talent maybe but in business
it's not really a thing who can be more
vicious adversaries men or women as far
as the the the commenting and the the
hate I think men categorically you know
I think there's a a little army of uh
really pale vitamin D deficient dudes in
basements who haven't achieved anything
that get triggered as by women who
have descri
Jack we're both very pale we're both
very pale hey come on man uh I don't
think a little darker I'm just hairy I
think it's just the hair that's I just
have a lot of makeup you can't even tell
like what is my real color who knows um
no I think I you know if you ask most
women on the internet uh who most of the
trolls are it's it's men it'd be f if
there's a study on that but I anticipate
that that's true pretty much across the
board and I actually understand why
because if men were told that
masculinity is tied to money and success
and that women will not choose you if
you don't make more money than them then
of course they're going to lash out at
women that have been more successful at
them and that have more money than them
because they've defined that as
masculine and they think that somehow
we're taking that away from them and
there's been a lot of you know women
that are tough on men these days so I
actually get it and some way shape or
form still pisses me off but um women by
and large are like nice on the internet
I mean the comments women have are like
it's the best you know they're like yeah
girl you do it BL you know thanks you
know but um maybe that's different if
you're like a Kardashian or beauty
expert I don't know yeah kind of a weird
question but what do you think about the
the culture in its entirety of like now
I feel like women are supposed to be
going into more high paying positions
you should be the girl boss this is like
what's right whereas beforehand it was
like you stay at home and I feel like
this is now the counterculture of of
that but then also this may be too big
of a switch and we're overcompensating
for something and now if you stay at
home and you're just just a wife I
shouldn't say just a wife but you're a
wife stay-at-home wife that's looked
upon in such a negative way what do you
think yeah I mean you're a bit damned if
you do damned if you don't for sure but
maybe it's not that different for men I
mean if you're a stay-at-home D dad
there's still a stigma like oh really
your wife runs all the money you stay at
home
um you know if you are a girl boss God I
hate that term but if you work for a
living whatever the it means that
you're a girl boss I don't know could
you imagine why do you hate the term
someone someone say a guy boss yeah he's
a a it because it sounds like a cutesy
sort of thing it's like oh yeah she's a
girl boss or do you what what does that
invoke for it's like you're juxtaposing
girl which is kind of like I feel like a
smaller you're just a girl boss it's
like it's it's showing that there's like
a big disparity between girl and boss
that's the reason why I feel like that
term exists rather
woman boss feels awful
to also well also why does it have to be
genderized boss you yeah also feels
gross maybe it's the word boss we get to
the root I mean I think uh
yeah imagine being a boy boss or a band
boss it also sounds awful I think all of
us should just um try to have ownership
over our own lives and leave it at that
but um no I think these days if you are
you know a powerful woman in a
professional sense there's also a
feeling like that's not great and in
fact I think that might be swinging more
you know there's all these we we talk
about this a lot at our company because
there's all these alpam men podcasts
that are out now that are like I was on
one the other day and they were like
what was a podcast no I I don't want to
out we could bleep it we'll we'll bleep
it bleep
it so he was on so I was On's podcast
who's uh a good friend but he was like
what does it mean to be a power cuffle
and you know and I was like I don't know
we're just a couple like that one of us
you know works and the other one works
too and we all work out and I think
there's this there's this movement of
like you know women for so long have
been in the homestead and now they're
coming out they probably came out a
little too strong in some ways like
men patriarchy whatever and now men are
like well kind of you right back
and so I think you know and so now the
the commentary is if you make too much
money you're actually not going to
attract a guy and there's all this data
that everybody is looking at and and I
by and large just don't buy into it do
you think there's some truth to that in
terms of the average that yeah yeah that
you are not average by any means I think
you're the exception to just about
everything so for you this doesn't apply
but like if you were to take pick like a
hundred average people throughout the US
do you think that would apply probably
but I mean think about it this way I
think anybody listened to this podcast
your entire reason you're listening is
because you don't want average average
the average American dies uh overweight
alone and broke that's just what the the
data says and so if that's true we sure
as don't want to be the average um
which means that we should strive for
something extraordinary and and I think
the bar is so low for above average
these days that it's actually not that
hard of a hurdle so let's say that it
that they right that our Buddy's right
that uh if you are monetarily successful
it will be harder for you to find a man
on average because uh you make more than
the average man does let's say that's
true we add to it going to the gym and
being kind of fit add to it being kind
of nice nicer than the average person
add to it being marginally funny and is
it really going to be that hard and I
think the answer is by and large no it's
just we want to find excuses for why
things so your advice for guys is they
got to be better I mean that flat out
the bar is set so low that you just both
sides I think okay like I mean I think
now I I mean from the male perspective I
could comment I do agree with you
completely I think the bar sit so low
that you just have to do above the
minimum to get ahead yeah and people
will complain about that but to me it
seems It's so unbelievably easy if you
just try most people won't even try so
well think about the confidence fact I
think dudes actually you guys have
interesting in a in a couple different
ways let's think about this three women
reasons women pick men that we hear
constantly right one is money that's the
easiest right two is looks maybe there's
four three is he's funny I like him
because he makes me laugh and four might
be he really confident you know he came
up and asked me out so if there's four
different legs on which the stool stands
which is the woman of your dreams that
you want like I think you should be able
to get one of the four so if you're not
you know if you're not the most
attractive guy if you're not the richest
guy can you be a pretty confident guy if
you're not the most confident guy can
you be a little bit funny and could you
be a little bit richer I don't know what
to do about looking ugly because I think
past sastic surgery for dudes is tough
but uh but yeah I think you got four
legs I have so many friends who have
husbands that maybe aren't as attractive
as they are or maybe aren't as wealthy
as they are but they're really funny or
they're really confident and Lord if
you're going to be with somebody until
you're 85 rather optimize for those two
things you don't think it's a money
thing you think it's a package thing if
you're lacking in one make up for it
with another yeah I do what is your
advice for women watching this who they
make 150 Grand 200 Grand a year they're
Highly Educated they have trouble
finding a person that matches or exceeds
their needs I do want to also make this
point real quick yeah I went on a date
with a girl I'm not going to say where
I'm not going to say anything love this
story because I got in a unfortunately I
got in a lot of trouble Josh if you're
watching this don't clip this up please
um thish I I went on someone else's
podcast brought this story up and then
it got posted as a clip she saw it and
got upset at me that I brought it up
don't know why I'm bringing it up again
because I could get in trouble Josh
don't clip this up I went on a date with
a girl that's the only detail I'm
providing and she said that she needs
the guy to make more money than her
period and she is a very successful
person she works at a elite level
high-paying job and she said in her
parents relationship the mom made more
than the dad and it caused insecurity
from the guy's perspective and that was
actually where a lot of the tension came
from was from his insecurity of her
making more than him do you see this as
like an issue with high earning women
generally speaking they're going to want
a guy that makes more than them I think
typically when this comes up I'd ask
questions like I'd say to that
girl is she single obviously yeah the
one I went on a date with she better I
don't know sing she could have a
boyfriend have a boyfriend now you can't
tell was she saying it like she was
having a hard time finding somebody
because this was a caveat that she has
uh she said dating
in oh she said cut that out and her name
was she she said dating was very
challenging in the location she lived in
yeah I mean women are going to hate me
for saying this on the internet I think
if you cannot find somebody that is a
you problem and not a them problem
because categorically there are enough
humans on this planet for all of us to
find our needs to be met and if you have
one I don't think you get to complain
when you have really strict parameters
like that like okay you either can say I
will only date somebody if they make
more money than I am and because of that
I know I have a limited reach of men and
so categorically it's going to be harder
for me to the date ipsofacto I shall not
complain but I think complaining about
something that is a self-prescribed
nonrational istic reason for you to do
it is a lesson in Insanity uh sorry
Carla or whatever her name is and but
number two I would say um like we all
need a little bit more therapy like you
know if you dug into that and I was
sitting with that woman I would say um
if you were to look if young if older
you was to look back on younger you and
you were to do it not from a place of
fear and not from a place of historical
PTSD and say that I'm so glad that I
married this man
because he made more money than me does
that seem rational and if if that
doesn't seem like a rational sentence
then why would you determine that as the
biggest reason why you date and I know
that didn't work out for your parents
but was it really only your father's
issue like do you think your mother had
any say in the reasons why he might have
felt insecure let me ask you this how is
that saying I want more than let's say
200 Grand a year any different from her
saying I want someone who's funny or I
want someone who's confident to me it
just seems she has four you know there's
four preferences on that list four legs
she's like one of those legs needs to be
this I'm flexible on the other three so
how is that different than saying I want
someone who's really confident well I
think it's not if older more thoughtful
her can look back and say thank God I
married this guy because he made more
money than I am that I did if she does
answer that question and say yes that is
that is what that is the core pillar in
a man that I want to spend the rest of
my life with okay fine but I think what
would actually happen instead is she
would go no I want him to be a good man
I want him to love me I want us to build
something really cool together I want
him to be an incredible father I want
him to make me laugh because I'm going
to care more about that during really
difficult times and I don't want us to
be despondent so I want him to work hard
all the time just like I will for our
goals but I think women these days are
slightly ridiculous I want them six2
$200,000 a year funny good-looking great
hair like William Defoe you know not
going to be every single man and so find
the things that actually matter that
reminds me of that delusion calculator
that you've seen on Tik Tok those little
Clips where they're like just describe
type of guy you want under the age of 40
yeah over six figures you're like yeah
uh you know not obese yeah and then it's
like0 like 1% of the population fits
that yeah and then they turn it back on
her and like what do you have to offer
and then like all the dudes are
like yeah that part's tough but I don't
think it's bad to have a mirror like you
know I don't know if you want the top 1%
be the top 1% and if you're not then
work on it and it's uh it's probably not
very popular to say these days but I
think we all would do so much better if
we just focused on us as opposed to why
other people are the reason why we don't
achieve the thing that we want to
achieve you know because even if that's
true that's not a very useful belief for
us to have so I'd rather have a useful
belief which is at the end of me
attempting to become the top 1% I'm the
top 5% that's pretty cool as
opposed to oh it's really hard to date
in New York and I'm not going to change
myself and I'm just going to swipe right
452 times there's that number again in
hell I find the perfect person which
seems to me again like you know Ben
Franklin's lesson in insanity is doing
the same thing continuously and
expecting a different result I do have a
random video that I would like to get
your opinion on if that's all right yeah
and I think it would be fun for Graham
to put his opinion forward I haven't
seen this video he didn't want to show
me amazing so many people have
philosophies towards money you know
people will say oh you got to save more
than you spend you got to not
have the Starbucks Coffee that's how
you'll get rich what is your overarching
philosophy to Building Wealth and money
do you have something like a philosophy
a
mantra well uh first I think you should
have the coffee I think that is
terrible advice um so I I like Dave
Ramsey I get where he's going with it
but um I think you cannot save your way
to wealth you can only earn your way to
wealth oh no should they not have the
coffee according to you no absolutely
not have the coffee absolutely don't
have the Mantra he built his entire
career off found that's my thing my
rationalization is that it's such loow
hanging fruit it's that one little thing
that you could start with and the type
of person who's not going and buying
coffee is also not going and doing a lot
of other things that waste money so no
it's not going to make you rich what can
actually if you if you go to Starbucks
at $5 every day compounded at an 8%
return over 40 something years that
could be a million box yeah especially
you do that in a Roth IRA it's taxfree
but I just see it as such a lwh hanging
fruit and something that you could do
yourself or a fraction of the price I
hate it I hate it um let me tell you why
I hate it I I only hate it uh because I
think there are two types of people I do
think they're either uh they're either
safety or upside people and I think for
a lot of people you're right they're
never going to focus on maximizing their
earnings in order to increase their
spending to whatever they want for a
safety focused person who wants to make
sure that they can live a really nice
life not have too volatility in it and
retire at a at a good you know age with
plenty of cash maybe don't drink the
coffee because you're never going to
optimize your earnings on the upside for
somebody who is focused on upside
earnings potential the only thing you
should be focused on in my opinion is
how do I make more money not how do I
save it uh because and that's from a
different side of the mathematical
equation which is I look at asymmetric
upside there's no such thing as
asymmetric downside because nobody can
really get enough debt unless you're a
billionaire to have unlimited downside
you have a limited downside especially
because we have bankruptcy in the US and
so you do not have a limited upside and
so if I just look at the math I can go
as high as I want but I can go as low as
zero to oversimplify what does that mean
I should always optimize for going
higher and but that is my type of
mentality I think you're right in the
perspective that a lot of humans are
never going to do that and so maybe
don't drink the coffee if you're more
concerned with safety than you are with
earnings there's a 2020 study that
showed that Millennials spent more money
on coffee than they did on retirement
and that is something that I think is
just unacceptable spend the money on
retirement get rid of the coffee yeah
start there start there it's easy it's
just so it's so simple what about the
other side of the coin why retire you
know lots of studies show well you don't
have to retire you're unhappy and that
you're more likely to die retire I don't
mean necessarily stop working I mean
that you have the means to be able to do
whatever you want to if it's if it's you
know working on a hobby in garage so be
it but it's having the means to be able
to do that or having the freedom to pick
and choose what you want to do with your
time so it's not like oh you get to sit
on the couch and watch TV yeah well I
think you're right like I heard another
one of your guests I can't remember who
say that they like to have zero dollars
in their bank account I could not
disagree with that more intensely
because oh yeah that was I think that
was Grant Cardone that makes sense yeah
um he spend your last, on a course was
his advice burn the bridges burn the
ships you you got to be at zero to push
you to make more I mean he has a bigger
bank account than I do um so I'll give
him that for sure I just don't like I
actually don't really like Risk I like
having some safety net or cushion for me
to take bigger and bigger bets um and
and I think that goes back to the Warren
Buffet ISM if you first rule of money
don't uh first rule of investing don't
lose money uh second rule don't forget
rule number one and so for me it's
always been this idea of how can I
actually protect the downside but I have
a good good friend that's become an
investor in one of my deals with me Bill
Perkins who wrote da zero he is always
telling me you are thinking too small
you are thinking too small and if you
are not willing to lose something then
you will never win something big and so
I think there's a there's a happy medium
between the two but you know could you
imagine a CEO of a company that's
publicly traded would go to jail if they
ran a company and they had Z doar in
Savings in that company that would be
considered a fiduciary liability brief
of their company and so Grant's private
so he can do whatever he wants
but you know the the the history shows
you that markets go up and down you
should keep something in reserve yeah
it's just math I I someone did that up
until 2020 where every year I'd invest
everything I had into real estate and I
would maybe have a few thousand in the
bank account when I was done so my goal
at the end of the year was spend
everything I had back into real estate
fixing up properties doing some sort of
renovation I wanted something and having
so little money in my banking account
was absolutely motivating for me now I
would absolutely not do it at this point
but back then my expenses were so low
that I could justify it and have like
three grand left over and just
immediately January 1st I would hustle
for the next deal and that was that was
a lot of motivation for me just to know
that like hey the bank account's down I
got to build it back up was that the
only way you could have motivated
yourself uh probably okay yeah when I
see that bank account go that low I'm
like oh man I got it cuz it it made me
appreciate the smaller deals yeah uh
like you know if I earned $500 on this
commission that on three grand is pretty
cool yeah but you know if I had $100,000
and I'm like why would I do the $500
deal oh it's like every little bit you
start to you really see the impact in
small amounts interesting yeah I could I
could see that I I just think I want to
make sure that I don't have something
that could wipe me out ever and the the
things that you can that can wipe you
out typically there's only really only
three of them and that's something
regulatory that the government could do
uh that's some sort of civil lawsuit uh
you know some sort of legal issue and
the third is running out of cash and so
um I do everything I can to protect from
regulatory overreach from uh lawsuits
and from running out of cash those are
the those are the business Killers what
do you do to protect yourself from
lawsuits have a lot of attorneys that I
pay a lot of money to uh you know the
thing nobody tells you about in business
is if you go into business you will be
stolen from be defrauded from be lied to
and probably be sued at some point it's
just the nature of our society today and
so the bigger you get the bigger Target
gets on your back and um and because of
that attorneys become your friends
because one you want to understand deal
terms and two you understand that um you
know at the end of the day there'll be
some sort of situation where um somebody
will want to take advantage I mean go
like drive down the freeways from the
airport to the strip what's on every
single billboard injury car accident
attorney attorney attorney why do they
do that those are expensive Billboards
because they make tens of millions of
dollars a year on people suing for
things that by and large probably they
shouldn't have sued for mhm and the part
that's crazy about our society is how
many people settle and how often you can
get sued for anything that's the other
people thing people don't realize like
they don't have to have a case you can
just get sued because somebody feels
like it we had a injury attorney on the
podcast recently interesting very
successful guy in
California and he was explaining
how his entire business model worked and
a lot of it comes down to what the
insurance companies are willing to
settle with because for a lot of
companies it's cheaper for them to say
I'm going to give you 50 Grand right now
it's done than to fight this thing to
court and it's a waste of time and
resources so for them if their client is
insured and they have proper limits the
attorney just needs to go in and say hey
we have this claim here's our evidence
we're going to take it to court or give
us 50 Grand and in most of those cases
they'll just say here's the 50 Grand
Grand yeah it's kind of a sad sad World
we're in I always wonder about I imagine
it'd be interesting to do a study but I
imagine that the people who get their
money through means like that are like
lottery winners it comes fast it goes
fast because when you don't actually
earn it or when you earn money from
something that you shouldn't have earned
it from I do believe that there's like
this karmic tie to money made and uh and
that it won't stick and so you know a
lot of the things that I talk about with
with making money and getting rich it's
not really because I want people to be
rich and have Lamborghinis and Drug
it's because I think that when you learn
to value your time in a way that ties to
ownership it changes your entire
perspective on life and it actually
makes you a better person because you
believe in yourself because you think
you can achieve things without having to
go after other people um and so I I
wonder about those people do you worry
that you're putting a Target on your
back by being so public about your
income who you are where you are all of
these things what's the advantage to you
on this yeah I mean I don't I don't talk
about my income anymore and increasingly
you know I was talking with some of our
friends about how how to talk about the
portfolio and I don't share all my
portfolio companies and I never have
because it does put a Target on those
companies which I don't think is fair
because they didn't sign up for that
like why does a roofing company in
Phoenix Arizona benefit from my big
platform it doesn't they're just going
to get more competitors and if I say
something silly then they're going to
get negative reviews that's no benefit
for them they shouldn't have to deal
with that um so I think there's
downsides and uh and increasingly like I
don't talk about exactly how much our
Revenue our portfolio companies do and
that's from a couple different reasons
not just a Target but also because what
about when it changes what about when I
sell one and then you know there's a
bunch of historical stuff saying it was
this amount now it's this amount what
about when it doubles just doesn't feel
it feels
misleading um but no it's all my husband
thinks about he's you know former
security military guy and he's very
concerned with security but I do think I
think a attention is the new currency in
a lot of ways I think it's an incredible
opportunity and privilege for people to
listen to you at all on the internet I
think it's really fun and um and I I do
truly believe which is maybe slightly
egotistical that we the world beor abhor
a vacuum right and if the only people
putting stuff on the internet are people
that are
relatively unethical are not really
giving any value then that's going to be
what's out there and I think we need
more humans who are doing the right
thing and talking about it and I wish
that I had somebody like you guys that I
could listen to when I was younger to
figure out this game of business and
success and life and money um and so I'm
willing to do that I think it's
interesting the longer I've been doing
YouTube the more private I've started
becoming I bet just just naturally the
less I want to share the less I want to
talk about things the more i' I'd like
to just kind of Remain the guy that's
why I love the podcast too is it's less
focused on myself and more focus on the
guest yeah and uh they they say like a
lot of wealthier people prefer just to
remain quiet and I could start to see
why initially I thought no they should
be you know on platforms giving advice
and helping people but I kind of see the
perspective of you know the advantage of
not having that sort of attention and
eyeballs on you yeah I it's it's a it's
an incredible privilege but it is also a
huge burden I think and you have to
you're a type of Personality that wants
and can deal with it I mean could you
imagine what for instance politicians go
through right now we're in election
period right can you imagine putting
their families through that that
immediately you sign up on one ticket or
the other and 50% of the company hates
or 50% of the country hates you um I
have a lot of respect for the people who
do it and then get out of it because
it's a it's a hard game but I'm with you
one of my favorite CEOs of all time uh
he scrubs himself off the internet
completely you can't find him anywhere
he's a multi- multibillionaire and um
and that's what what he said to me back
in the day he was like we get rich
quietly here we don't talk about it
publicly and I did not understand it
then and now I get it a little bit and I
I do respect it why did he try to be so
secretive with that like to that degree
to like nothing online about this person
I actually the two richest guys I know
are like that uh one I I sat on the
board of their hedge fund for a long
time you can't find him anywhere he
would be pissed if I mentioned his name
on a podcast um and I think it is
because of that you know there is a
feeling in this country and around the
world that uh if you are rich you didn't
earn it if you are rich uh there's
something bad or wrong with you and that
uh you should be pulled down and in fact
I do think the tall poppy syndrome is
true that you know when we see a poppy
that rises above the rest it gets picked
right um and and I think that happens
across our country and many others but
we have to you just have to choose what
type of person you want to be you know
do you want to be do you want to be the
warrior or do you want to be the
gardener and you know my husband really
inspires me to do a lot of this but I
think that we are at a let me get on my
soap box for a second I think we are at
a critical Tipping Point in our country
and the developed world for uh making
sure that people realize they're not
victims they can have opportunity and
that those who win win because they work
at it and that's available for everybody
and if if we don't have people out here
saying that more often um then I think
our country doesn't look very good for
our kids if we choose to have those in
decades mhm what are your weaknesses
what do you think is what do you think
you should be working on um a lot uh I
mean I have a terrible memory um I
forget everything all the time um I also
uh I forget loose with numbers I forget
exactly the numbers of deals so now I've
I've started saying more like I don't
remember the exact numbers here's what I
think it is plus or minus 10 to 30% um I
do not have that kind of photographic
memory do I think that I can get better
at that though I don't actually know I'm
matter yeah maybe it'd be really nice if
I could prattle off some of the people
that come on here they they say the
numbers so specifically they remember
every aspect of and I've never been like
that um but to your point I try to focus
on the things I'm good at as opposed to
optimizing for my biggest weaknesses and
instead of optimizing for those I hire
for those and so it's like can we you
know team can you make sure that I have
numbers somewhere if I need to reference
them can I like have a place where I can
say I can't remember what that deal was
but go look at our site here's the
numbers on the site um but that's one of
my bigger weaknesses for sure and I like
to work probably more than I should how
much do you work a lot um I I really
like it maybe at some point if I have a
kid I'll like the kid more than working
but uh but right now it's it's my
favorite thing to do um you know like
what a weird job we have now like think
about this I remember you know people
would say I'm so tired from recording
all this stuff you know I'd look at the
team and I'd go we're doing
YouTubes we're doing Tik toks as opposed
to spread sheets for 400 hours at
Goldman Sachs like this is this is
Barney's playtime and uh and so I think
that's not always the best perspective
to have it means that I'll do things for
a lot longer than I should and I and I
certainly don't focus on you
know I don't know Health as much as I
should maybe although that word should
bothers me I try not to use it too often
so what does your daily routine look
like really standard I'm a big believer
in the the Small Things replicated
continuous ly allow for you to not have
decision fatigue so I don't want to have
to question every single decision I eat
the same thing for breakfast I order the
same thing for lunch or what do you get
for breakfast very simple I'm all
protein right now so I eat steak and
eggs steak and eggs yeah what kind of
steak
uh it's w it is I don't know I'm not
that particular about food um at all my
husband's more no we just my husband
loves to cook or we order pretty
continuously we own part of a couple
restaurants in Austin the don't use seed
oils don't you
own L we'll go to Austin we'll be like
hey we need to rental car be like no I
own a place that does that I don't own
that you want insurance we I own that
place too I would like to own that yeah
um so yeah steak and eggs in the morning
like around 10 o' a coffee with uh with
ghee in it um ghee in the coffee what's
ghee why do you add ghee it's like fat
right it's like yeah I don't actually
know what it is it's called like theprof
coffee yeah exactly yeah um um so that's
just basically uh I'm pretty sensitive
to coffee and so if I have a lot of
coffee I'll get all jacked up and
jittery I'm already I already run pretty
hot and so having fat inside of the
coffee decreases apparently that
jitteriness with coffee so we have half
calf coffee not full calf we have ghee I
get rolling out of bed I drink big thing
of water um and I go to work and then I
work for a period and then I do like the
same thing for lunch like protein steak
something like that and then uh and then
then I probably go work out and then I
work until pretty late uh and then I do
dinner with my husband every night is
non-negotiable so we always do dinner
together uh we no phones no TV um we're
not drinking right now but typically
like a nice glass of wine the two of us
and we have a little conversation um
that's focused on you know what we did
that day and what we want to do the next
day what we want to achieve next how do
you work on your marriage and make sure
you guys are on the same page it's my
biggest priority and so in life uh I
think you can only really focus on three
things at a time really well and so you
know it for me it's always first and
foremost my husband the second that I
decided to get married that was the most
important thing uh second is my business
um and the third is my health and um and
so we're pretty fanatical about our
relationship uh we hang out more than I
would assume most couples do he runs our
portfolio on the media accelerated side
um and I think you know one of the nice
Parts about us working together it's
interesting because your studio you know
is here and your fiance is here too I
really believe in work life integration
and so I take Chris along with me and so
you know he comes to most travel trips
he's not this week because he couldn't
but we almost always traveling together
uh we do most meetings together um he's
a great relationship manager and like
continuer and executor of things I'm a
great starter and bringing people inner
uh of things and so we work really well
together in that way and then we always
have something to talk about you know do
you believe in separate or joint
accounts I don't think I have a hard
stance either way on that I think we
have separate and Joint so you have mine
his hours M yeah why do you do it that
way not out of any particular reason one
way or the other I mean again I I have a
philosophy overall right maximize
earning maximize earnings so I'm never
really concerned with what he's spending
or what I'm spending he's much more
thoughtful on spending I think that
comes from the military he's much more
programmatic um but in the beginning
yeah for sure he would have been the one
that set rules and parameters around it
I've always been a little bit loose and
he's been like you know no what's yours
is yours what's mine is mine and I don't
really believe in that do you believe in
prenups yeah I only believe it because I
believe in expectation setting and so um
anything after the marriage you know
50/50 anything before was his or mine um
pretty clean and um I don't think
emotional I didn't have a prenup last
time so that was painful what did that
look like when you split without the
prenup yeah I mean it was it was pretty
quick because I wanted it done but my
dad said a great line to me at the time
I was struggling because I was going to
have to pay a lot of money and he said
there's an exit tax to Freedom every
time and so I just remembered that when
I had to write a check and do whatever
which was there's going to be an exit
tax but you know divorce is awful I
don't wish it on anybody it's miserable
and it's it's both people's fault nine
times out of 10 M and so it was my fault
just as much as it was his and um it's
miserable and I remember like you know
my credit card's getting cut off and my
bank account getting cut off because it
was joint but it was in his name even
though I you know it was a mess um and
it took a long time to recover from that
it's also very very expensive for the
typical you know person um and so I have
a lot of empathy for people going
through divorce I think most of it can
be I don't know how to not have people
get divorced what I do know is that you
can decrease a lot of your financial
stress around Divorce by a prenup
setting expectations and both parties
always knowing where the money is and
having equal access to the money and I
think that's just good partnership so
when you split with or I should say when
you got the initial divorce um that was
one lumpsum payment that you had to make
it wasn't like some sort of like
continual spouse no I didn't have I
didn't have that he earned well I earned
well I do remember at the time and I was
like you he uh he asked for a
percentage of my future earnings tried
to negotiate that and I was like the
thing is get um but uh but I
guess it was a compliment because he
thought I might earn a lot in the future
yeah yeah when did you realize that was
a bad fit and what is your advice to
people who are in relationships or maybe
they don't know if it's a good fit like
when did that realization come to your
mind most I got married because I
thought that's what you did I thought
you find a nice person that you're
attractive to that you're attracted to
that successful um that you kind of have
fun with and you get married and you
have kids and you settle down and uh I
prescribed to all the social norms and
when I found that and he proposed we got
married and I thought that was just the
next check off the book The Box terrible
idea if I looked back uh I would be a
lot more particular it was the one area
of my life where I think I settled and I
felt bad which I think happens to a lot
of people on both sides you say yes to
marrying somebody because you would feel
bad saying no what you already have
confirmation bias you've been with them
for a period of time why haven't you
left if you aren't going to say yes to
getting married um you know the other
person pressures you hey I want to get
married hey I want this to happen sooner
if there's any doubt or inkling in your
mind about should you get married in my
instance I think don't because uh it's a
long road and it's very difficult and I
do think it's a
beautifully kind of sacred thing to live
your life with another human and you
should be really particular about the
one that you decide to do it with was is
there a Breaking Point that like
something switched where like this just
isn't working out there's no way to fix
this yeah I mean we wanted two different
lives right I think a lot of times when
you get married you think your person's
going to change your person's not going
to change they are who they are and
they've had you know 25 years of
compounding to the person that they are
today that cement is set and he assumed
that I was going to change and I assumed
he was going to change he thought one
day I'd want the white picket fence and
the two and a half kids and that one day
would be a lot sooner and I thought he
would chill out from the you know clubs
and drinking and Wall Street and all the
craziness and he didn't want to and so
um we both set poor expectations and we
thought we could change the other person
to our purview now I think he's
perfectly happy and on his own thing but
don't expect your other person to change
because the likelihood is low what is
your advice to new couples to make sure
they don't end up in that
situation I think you should sit down
and have a conversation it's what Chris
and I did we sat down and the internet
loves to laugh at this they're like
that's really romantic like that sounds
awful I'm like all right man go through
a divorce um but you know him and I sat
down and we basically just said what do
we want out of life what are our really
big visions and we had that I think
cemented us more than anything our
visions and our values and the vision
was we wanted to build an empire
together we wanted to see could we
squeeze every single drop of capability
out of both of us before we die uh and
wouldn't that be fun to try can we
continue to play the game at the highest
level possible not just how much money
we make but how much can we contribute
how much are we actually capable of
what's the limit what that feel like to
hit it and we both wanted that we didn't
want to live small lives and we were
honest about that and then second uh was
our values and that was if we get
married do we do this for life you know
um how do we want to raise kids how do
you think about lying cheating stealing
uh what if one person feels something
for another person do we talk about it
or not um like we got pretty granular
and we put up a whiteboard and we both
kind of workshopped this and I learned
this through therapy in my first
marriage and I wish I would have done it
before because it's really really it's
very revealing have you done something
like that with yeah yeah we did the
whole marriage counseling beforehand uh
and there's a whole bunch of like
questions but honestly a lot of the
questions I knew like I think Macy and I
on like second or third date we went
through practically everything to make
sure yeah CU I think we're both on the
same page like hey if it's if either one
of us deviate from this and it's just
not the right fit let's figure it out
know yeah so like why waste time if it's
if if we know there's going to be a
sticking point somewhere so I think we
kind of threw everything at the at the
wall I love that it's actually it's also
kind of sexy because then you know you
know your other person is going to be
with you through it all because you've
already you've already talked about it
and it doesn't mean they can't change
their mind but they're probably not
going to change their mindset so I do
think the Carol DW fixed first growth
mindset is really critical too you know
my my ex-husband had a fixed mindset we
are this way I am this way it is this
way and mine was like well we're that
way now but like couldn't we continue
growing changing evolving and I think if
you are a growth mindset there's nothing
worse than being with a fixed mindset
and figuring out that fast yeah what do
you think the biggest uh red flags are
for relationships how things begin is
usually how they end and so if your
relationship begins because you two were
cheating red flag if your relationship
begins and it's tumultuous and hard red
flag if your relationship begins and you
two don't have a lot in common and that
bothers you and it's slightly boring red
flag and so um that people are at their
best when they're trying to impress you
in the beginning and I do think at some
point it gets better like that happened
to Chris and I our first year of
marriage was definitely the hardest it's
like how do two fully formed adults come
together and compromise on things and
feel okay about both being slightly
unhappy in our compromise um but after
that first year you know it's gotten
easier do we fight absolutely you know
the team's all seen it but do we have
the same vision and values it's so clear
that we know that at the end of the day
you know if he called me from a third
world jail I'd figure out how to get him
out do you want kids yes when I'd like
him sooner rather I'm 37 so you know
time clock on the overies but uh you
know sooner rather than later I think um
but it's not something that I always
wanted and so often I think women seem
to either know right away that they want
them or they wait for the right partner
in the right time and then they feel
like they might want them why do you
want kids when I talk to a lot of people
I feel like that are similar to you or
like on your level uh like Tom Bilu he's
like no I don't want to have kids I
don't want anything that distracts me
I'm nervous I'm going I love my kid more
than I love my work and I love my work
so much Alex Orosi says no I I fear that
I would hate my kid like why why are you
the exception why do you want kids I
want to have the full Human Experience I
think that we probably only get one shot
on this planet and that
uh reproduction seems to be something
that is programmed into us to desire in
some way shape or form and I want to be
a part of that I want to feel what that
feels like um I also think there's
something beautiful about this idea of
legacy and what what would make me work
harder than having a human who was
completely reliant on me working hard
and maybe trying to make some effect on
the planet that could have help them one
way or the other and so for me I'm the
opposite I imagine that my dedication to
what I do is going to 10x it's kind of
Roi still like lens yeah 100% um but I
don't you know I didn't ever have that
matriarchal I want to hold the baby I
want to feel it in my belly situation a
surrogate I would like not to um again I
think bonding happens through extreme
trial right and so nothing more extreme
than what you go through with pregnancy
and with child birth and so that seems
like a pretty incredible thing to
attempt um first of all and then second
I don't have any shame one way or the
other with surrogacy but there's a lot
of that's a lot of intricacies and
nuances with that that um that I would
hope to avoid but I have a lot of very
successful friends that are like it
ship in a surrogate you know um I'm not
necessar that necessarily that way how
do you ensure that you'll raise kids
with the values that you want them to
have I I don't think you can be sure of
anything with children you know maximum
level of hubus is the parent who says I
shall never ex before they have a child
right who knows um I'm going to attempt
to do just slightly better than my
parents did um and hope that uh as Chris
and I like to say I up our kids
just enough to be a Navy SEAL or a
private Equity investor and not a
stripper um you know and uh like I think
every child I mean talk to somebody who
has parents and they don't think that
the parents did something wrong I
haven't met one yet so I'm sure our kids
will have many of things that they think
we did poorly um but what a beautiful
challenge to attempt what are your
thoughts on Modern Freedom hierarchy oh
yeah um so this is why I started
contrarian thinking uh basically this
idea that I was obsessing on how do we
get people to think critically so I saw
not a lot of that was happening in
2020 and um and what I realized is
people it's maso's hierarchy of needs
but slightly changed the hierarchy goes
first as the base level you have to have
physical Freedom right like you have to
be able
to I don't know live in the house that
you want to live have your body be you
know safe healthy Etc second level after
that you can have Financial Freedom
Financial Freedom meaning I can spend
what I want where I want with whom I
want and the final level being
philosophical Freedom like only after
you have your physical freedom your
Financial Freedom can you get to
philosophical freedom because when
you're just trying to pay your rent and
you're trying to get out of debt you are
in a fight or flight stance you cannot
stand for you know morals and high
grounds at least it's much harder to and
so I think if we could get more people
to a status in which they're not figh or
flighting they can stop they can breathe
and they can think critically we
probably have a much different country
so our idea with contrarian thinking is
all right let's see if we can get more
people to be financially free and then I
think I can get them to think think
critically and that was our bet our
trojan horse is money and out of the
Trojan Horse spills hopefully critical
thinking because of skin in the game
that you have when you own something how
did your values beliefs or perspectives
change once you obtain philosophical
freedom I could say and do a lot more
things when I had the you Fund in
hand you know I think um so be more
forthright with your opinion yeah so but
your philosophy didn't necessarily
change it was more so oh I get ability
yeah like um did My Philosophy change
once I already had Financial Freedom did
I change my mind so for example we've
brought people on this podcast before
Destiny was one person who is like a
liberal political commentator and as he
gained more money he actually it it kind
of solidified and validated his liberal
policy prescriptions which I found very
interesting because that kind of runs
against what most people think so like
as he obtained more wealth and he
eclipsed the uh Financial Freedom to the
physical freedom to the philosophical
Freedom like how did your own philosophy
change I'm not sure that my philosophy
well I do think that uh the worst thing
that you can do is have uh opinions
strongly held I think that you should
have opinions loosely held um and you
should debate them fiercely and so My
Philosophy changes frequently as soon as
I get new inputs I want to evolve the
philosophy that I have I don't think
there was a magical moment at which
point it changed maybe the Only Magical
moment was the first moment that I
really became responsible for a company
I think that was a pivotal moment in my
career because it was the moment that I
understood every bad boss every you know
tough decision my parents like once you
own a p&l somebody's livelihood um
you're the person in charge you're
responsible it flipped my mindset
because no longer could I have excuses
about why things didn't happen I was all
up to me like there was nobody else in
the way um so that did change my mindset
hugely it's like oh man the buck
actually does stop with you um it was
hugely freeing but it was really hard
you know you really have to look
yourself hard in the mirror I think at
that point who' you say is your idol or
like your your main
Mentor I never liked the word
Mentor uh because I I think i' have
never met another human that I want to
change lives with you think that's what
Mentor means I think mentor to me often
means you follow somebody and they guide
you through to achieve what they've
achieved and I I've found like a
holistically pure Mentor I've probably
found mentors in finance mentors in
relationships so like maybe not an
overall Mentor but I've had specific
mentors like Graham has been a mentor my
father's been a mentor maybe even a
professor at a college has been a mentor
you know problem is with mentors did you
ever ask gram to be your
Mentor no of course not that's I think
the student makes the mentor the exactly
I think that's my problem with today A
lot of people are like will you be my
mentor or will such and such be my it's
like no no no your Mentor can happen
from somebody you've never met if all
you do is read the books even long after
they've died and so I suppose if we talk
about a mentor that way like they don't
even know but they are then I've had
many many of those um let I think about
who that is lately I mean there's a
couple people I'm going to say Bill
Perkins probably recenty bias but what I
love about Bill he does not care about
what anybody thinks he will be friends
with people because he wants to be
friends with them even if it's not
convenient I think that is very rare
today I think people do not want to
choose sides and especially for people
that are on the internet they're only
willing to go so far if it doesn't
further their value Bill Perkins is not
that man he does not care and so like
for instance I'm not a big Dan bazarian
fan but Bill's great friends with Dan
because Bill thinks that Dan is
something different than what the
internet portrays him at even though
that's probably degrading to Bill's
reputation and I have a lot of respect
for that um so bill for his like
you mentality and also he's always
thinking bigger I remember I went to him
I have this big business that we're
going to launch this year I bought it
we're going to plow a couple million
dollars in it I have a huge like two
huge investors and I plow a couple
million of their own into it and it's
going to be my big billion dollar bet
this year we'll see if it works and um
and I brought the idea to him and I
remember he looked at me at his like big
mansion overlooking awestin Lake and
he's like I I think I'm presenting him
with like an incredible idea and he's
like do you think that you've been
around small business for so long that
small has infected your thinking and I
was like it's kind of rude and and then
as I thought about it I was like well
maybe because you're right we could
actually do this and it could be bigger
this way and so he's another Mentor for
always pushing me to think bigger and I
often think the people that can be the
best mentors to you are the ones that
they've kind of already achieved and so
and they don't have a lot of reasons
like they don't really care what you do
they they've already achieved what they
need to achieve they're just kind of
sitting on the sidelines going I'd like
to be able to cheer for somebody and
Bill is one of those for sure do you
think we have a problem here in the US
that people are just not critically
thinking why do you think that is so I
think the problem with critical thinking
is uh it makes you stand out from the
crowd and none of us actually really
like that like we think we want to stand
out for the crowd we want to get like
kind of famous but we actually don't
want to stand out that much from the
crowd and critical thinking just means
that you're doing that constantly
non-stop over time and then you also
have to be able to have the ability to
hold two things in your mind at the same
time that might not both be true or that
might both be true have real cognitive
dissonance and that's tough for most
humans it's much easier to go I'm I'm a
liberal I'm a conservative as opposed to
well I have some components of this and
some components of this and they both
are bad and they both are good in
varying ways hard to do actually and
probably because we aren't taught that
anymore we're taught in 60-second sound
bites do you think shorts are destroying
attention spans I think Tik Tock is
digital fenyl and we should regulate it
as such I think the way that we are fed
information into our brains in 20 years
we will look back on and think how did
we allow this to happen to our youth in
particular I think my generation and
maybe both of your guys' too got really
lucky because we skipped growing up our
entire lives with the ability to
Non-Stop self-record and Screen
ourselves and so
that would be one thing I try to do if I
had children would be to sincerely limit
what input goes in I mean it's the same
thing as I think we will realize and I'm
sure there's studies out there that show
this already but that there is no
question in our minds right now if I eat
only fast food and if I eat only
processed things I shall probably become
sick right we would be pretty safe
saying that I think in the future we
will look back and think if I consume
only negative news if I consume only
trash and nonsensical things I shall be
sick in some way shape or form and I
think that yes some social platforms are
doing that and you have to fight back
aggressively on what you allow into your
mind just like you do what's allowed
into your mouth does that mean you
contribute to the platform because
you're there to make it better or do you
believe that contributing to a platform
like Tik Tok is only going to bring more
people in and eventually they'll win my
thought and I thought long and hard on
this so one I don't have Tik Tok on my
phone so I do not actually consume
anything on Tik Tok ever and I thought
long and hard about getting off of Tik
Tok entirely but my counterweight to it
is our youth is there and so if our
youth is there maybe it's our job
actually to create better more
interesting content that has a white
pill in it as opposed to a black pill in
it and so that's our mission for the
next couple of years can we make
financial literacy positive mindset
growth just as interesting as teenagers
dancing in unison and I don't know the
answer to that but we're going to try
just out of curiosity why such a large
ring oh yeah I always wear them you know
you know what nobody's ever asked me
that what if you get in a fight and you
have to that's that's right that's what
it was that is you know I'm always
nearly in fights it's it's very I mean
it's as big as the face on your watch
yeah it is um slightly smaller okay um
it actually it stems from my uh my
grandmother my great- grandmother Evelyn
she always used to wear really big rings
and I think there's something uh there's
something about having a piece of
fashion that's signature that I always
liked and so for a long time I didn't
care about fashion at all and I thought
that it didn't matter and now I actually
think it does I think it matters a lot
the way you're you the way you look in
the first seconds that you are perceived
is very hard to take off of somebody's
mind once they've made them and so I
think having like sort of a signature
look having a piece of having fashion
that you take seriously is actually
really beneficial and so I've thought
about that a lot of lately and then this
was her ring so I wear a lot of these in
tribute to her I got a crazy one we're
goingon to do a 180 is the American
dream dead oh yeah um want to hear
something wild
yeah what percentage and you already
know don't you have you read that yet
red what okay well I'm not gonna ask the
question because I think you guys might
already know the answer but the audience
won't you might not know okay what
percentage of millionaires do you think
America has as opposed to the whole
world
I'm going to take a
guess
85% you think 85% of millionaires live
in the US as opposed to the rest of the
world 80 I'm going to say 80 okay uh in
the US I'd say
60% maybe 50 okay you guys are very
positive the answer is 42% 41.9% CL so
the American dream is not dead on the
ice coffee Hour podcast but regardless I
thought about that and and it's wild
when you look at act the actual
population of the world we have almost
half of all millionaires live in the US
and so when people say to me the
American dream is dead well there is no
other country in which the American
dream is more alive so just
mathematically we own more people who
have more money than anywhere else in
the world but assuming you don't have a
million dollars let's say assuming
you're eight you just turned 18 YP don't
have a million is that American Dream
debt just because people have a million
dollars already doesn't mean that you're
going to get a million dollar good point
forward looking all right well we could
look at a different way so a study came
out recently that said about $3.4
million is what is needed for one
human's entire lifetime to achieve the
American dream yeah I'd be curious your
take after this so like $3.4 million
pretty standard things house cars kids
funerals um I thought that was
interesting and they were saying it like
this was this huge number and then I was
like well let's look at the underlying
assumptions which we should always do
when we see numbers and I'm like okay
they start this from 18 and then the
average person in the US dies at 77 so I
can't remember what's 77 it's like 59 59
years between the two so if we divide
3.4 million is by 59 we we reach
something like $58,000 a year is what
you need to achieve $3.4 million in
lifetime earnings one pretty reasonable
the average American in the US uh the
average American salary is somewhere
between $3 to $60,000 depending on how
you but that's starting at 18 which
18year olds are not going to have that
income and that's also after tax oh oh
the $3.4 million is is after tax that's
also not assuming any growth of income
yeah and yeah lots of starting off at 18
I don't know I believe you're probably
most people probably not going to have
that income until late 20s I think
there's a lot of things that could be
sideways with numbers 30 you know
definitely starting at 18 maybe you
can't make 30k you could also say what
about inflation it's not actually 3.4
it's going to be higher at some point
but let's let's be and then on the other
side it's of course well are you going
to earn $558,000 forever no and so I
think the answer is it's actually more
achievable than even I thought um I
think even if we take those so when do
you actually start earning something
like 30k a year when you're 21 or 22
Yeah well you graduate college at 22 so
probably and so you're in the interim
you're probably making if you have a
part-time job I don't know 10 to 20K a
year a server uh you know a bender
unless you go to college with debt yeah
you know and you graduate at 22 and
you're like negative 50,000 you could
yeah I think college throws a huge
wrench into a lot of this and that I
think is real um but to me that seemed
like wow the American dream is actually
slightly more attainable than I thought
it was and especially if we don't do
what people tell us to typically do
which is go to like a quite mid-tier
very expensive college yeah um so I
don't think the American dream is dead
but I do think it's under attack and so
to your point like if we have inflation
where it's at if we we have high
interest rate numbers if we have the
highest asset price numbers that we have
if we don't continue to build more homes
if we have uh tuition continue to go at
the level that it's going at and if we
increasingly don't have wage growth
which is something that has been
stagnant for some time I do think that
we're under attack but I don't think the
solutions are going to be the things
that a lot of politicians are talking
about at like Ubi and um you know
overall allowances for minimum wage
increases I saw that I thought the
numbers were really High actually like
$35,000 was the amount that they put in
for the average wedding plus a ring yeah
I think you could easily do without that
uh then they also assume M wasn't even
that I think Chris bought my wedding no
I was like a a little wedding ring
nothing fancy I think it cost like eight
or 10K and we make a lot of money why do
you need a $35,000 ring that's crazy oh
it wasn't it was the uh the ring and the
W how much is your can you say how much
your whole thing's costing you um I
think at this point we're trying to keep
it under 20 grand yeah that's incredible
everything yeah well especially because
I think sometimes especially when maybe
people think about how much money we
both might have they assume you know you
see most people who have a lot of money
have a giant ring because it's like a a
signal somehow know I love the
understated aspect of it yeah why um
same thing with a wedding you know if
you threw a party and you threw a party
that cost 20K your friends would be like
this is a sick party but you throw a
wedding that cost 20K and people think
that's
cheap yeah yeah so the wedding is one
thing a l of or a then it also assumes
you buy new buy a six-year-old car every
years if you just drive a six-year-old
car every 8 to 10 years that skews the
numbers and then people were saying that
they're double counting the cost of
raising a child which I think there was
two kids $550,000 over the course of a
lifetime but that also was baked into
the cost of housing of like $800,000 of
of having a larger house so I think they
were double counting some of those
numbers so just assuming you cut some of
those out oh and then it was also the
cost of health insurance which was like
$700,000 over the course of a lifetime
which is to me insane any employer is
going to cover a significant portion of
that no one's having more than like a
$5,000 deductible a year if you're if
you're employed throughout that part so
it's like I bet the American dream would
probably cost more like two million
bucks is is maybe 2.2 give or take if
you to be reasonable about it yeah which
means you would easily cover it
with you know let's call it somewhere
between 30 and
60,000 in earnings but that also assumes
that you only have a one income earning
household yeah it also from the age of
18 if you die at 77 or you're going to
die at 77 and not have the part that
that I thought was wild is when you look
at the the great everybody's talking
about the baby boomer wealth transfer
right and I think they're totally
getting it wrong because they're talking
about it like the average baby boomer
God I'm going to mess up the numbers
slightly but let's say the average baby
boomer maybe you know has
$265,000 that they're going to um
transition to their kids but the problem
with that is that baby boomer needs that
to laugh throughout their lifetime
including even if we say that Medicare
Medicaid continues um the cost of
retirement homes and getting sick is so
high now that that $265,000 if that's
what they have uh you know call it like
let's call it like 70 years of age and
increasing we we're living more to like
85 86 years old will actually be gone by
the time that baby boomer dies and so
they might you they might hand you down
not they could hand you down but they
might die in debt or they hand you down
a very small amount of money instead of
uh 265,000 so that's why I'm so
passionate about people transitioning
businesses because I think all the money
is actually in business and assets not
liquid cash this would have been a
perfect place place for you to say and
that's why I own assisted living
facilities I bought them last year no I
don't that would be a great business to
to buy into it would if you could do it
nicely I the numbers show that
increasingly a lot of them are owned by
private Equity players and there's a lot
of problems with over uh with over
focusing on profit in my opinion in that
sector and so there's so many horror
stories it's it's not something that I
would roll up and grow unless I was
really not focused on on profit can you
imagine like a 95-year-old can't pay
their monthly rent and they don't have
any family and they don't have any money
left and you're going to like kick them
out on the street I don't I try to stay
out of like okay I won't wash your car
fine okay like I won't wash your clothes
in the laundro mat fine but I'm not
going to kick out a 95-year-old out of
the building that can't afford to stay
there that'd be awful awful yeah I
remember seeing in the news this was
about 10 years ago father bought a condo
for his daughter near USC and there was
someone who's living in there like a
veteran of course in their 9s he bought
the condo and was evicting this person
because the daughter was going to move
in to go to college well of course this
person has nowhere else to go they've
lived there for 30 years and you had
this split down the middle where the
news was villainizing the owner but the
owner was saying I have a legal right to
this unit to do with as I please and
reading the comments about that was you
had I would say half the people thought
this guy was the worst in the world the
other half of the people said it's his
right it's it's not his fault that this
person didn't save up for this but
that's a difficult position either way
and I think at the end they ended up
helping this person find another
facility or something like that it was a
pretty positive ending but it either way
it's just it's bad all the way around
yeah I try to avoid businesses like that
but that's you know that's what people
can't do today no cognitive dissonance
they can't hold in their mind this is
sad and maybe bad and simultaneously the
guy has every right which is both true
right um yeah and yeah and it's in
California so I'm actually am you could
even evict the guy yeah you could evict
as an owner user in plenty of situations
um I think in that case if they were
there less than 10 years in certain
buildings over the age of 50 65 you you
could legally get them out yeah but
there are all these restrictions on what
is a protected tenant in Los Angeles
County oh yeah I remember I mean you
know way more about real estate than I
do but we own a series of of airbnbs and
we don't uh we don't allow anybody to
stay over 30 days in California because
of of the you hear about the dentist guy
in Los Angeles yes he's the one that the
person lived there for how long yeah
years never paid rent and then asked him
for $100,000 to leave do you hear about
this Jack oh it's crazy this guy listed
his unit on Airbnb and this lady came to
him and said I want to rent here for
like 6 months he said perfect well guess
guess what she moved in didn't pay and
so he says didn't pay a single time she
she paid like the move in just like a
little bit of money to rent his guest
house that he like and this is a
multi-million dollar home in Brownwood
so this is like a four to6 million house
and he's renting up the guest house she
doesn't pay well he tries to evict her
and she says no no you can't evict me
because this is not permitted you didn't
get a certificate of occupancy and
technically the lease I have is invalid
you can't evict me and she hires a
lawyer and sure enough he could not
evict her the city wouldn't wouldn't
help him because they say well you
didn't get a certificate of occupancy
when you when you built this place so
technically that's between you two and
it took years and he got to a point
where he had nowhere else to turn she
had been there for two years not paying
anything apparently it was really
hostile between them and so he got media
coverage and this lady become became
like a micro celebrity and she had
Paparazzi outside of her house and they
would follow her to like restaurants and
did people like her no no they didn't
like her but they would speculate on
like oh she's going to dinner with this
guy who is this guy they just invaded
her privacy and then she uh and then she
asked for $100,000 to leave he said no
that got even more attention and
eventually she moved she voluntarily
just left and it was a big thing I mean
there was like news outlets and
helicopters like taking photos because
it was on a hillside in Brownwood and
they're like taking photos of the inside
showing like people moving out of this
place like it was a big deal but the
owner said he had no idea that this
certificate of occupancy was never
released because he hired a contractor
to do it and just assumed that when they
finished the job everything was good so
he was oblivious to it but it was just a
crazy situation and now oh and also
apparently she has a history of doing
this oh yeah so this is not her first
time like she'll purposely seek out
places that she knows she could rent
live in there for as long as she can use
the system to her advantage and then
just find another place when she leaves
so what kind of a lawyer would represent
her in this situation how is he making
money off of that you you have to think
there are there are plenty of public
defendants out there that will just get
paid by the state uh and a especially a
state like California will have people
on retainer for people who just can't
afford their services everyone has a
right to legal
representation yeah that's a good point
well and there's so many people that'll
do it on contingency she could have even
paid him some like hey if I don't have
to pay two years worth of rent I'll pay
you 3 months of 15% of rent cost or%
rent cost oh yeah and her rent I think
was like four grand a month $5,000 a
month so how did she get access to a
public defendant if she had the income
to rent a place maybe she didn't have
the income maybe she just moved in and
said hey I'm going to sign four five
grand a month I'm going to rent it maybe
she didn't I'm sure there's some
requirements that you would have to
prove that you can't afford a certain
person those are the hard Parts about
ownership right and especially real
estate it is you're dealing with you're
dealing with humans and time you're
dealing with humans it gets tough yeah
but that story was wild there was one in
orgon that was like similar too really
yeah but he he had to live in his van
outside of the house because he rented
his house out for a period and then he
couldn't afford anymore to cover the
house and so he had to live in his van
well the yeah the the ones that upset me
the most are the squatters yeah when
someone can't move in their house
because a squatter has somehow broken in
and then they can't evict them that to
me makes no sense and there was a story
of a lady who uh uh bought a house got
the keys on the closing day went inside
the house and there's squatters in there
and she's like I have my moving truck
here I sold my house I'm supposed to
move in here but these people now claim
a right to the property so the police
come and the people have forged a lease
and the police say sorry this is a so
you're going to have to go through the
eviction process I just Clos on the
house I don't know who these people are
well they've been living here for the
last few days or whatever and they say
they have a lease we can't evict them
that makes no sense in my mind that they
could just take over a property and say
no I'm staying here and it takes months
ended up taking I think something like
six months to a year and they trashed
the place it shouldn't happen yeah um do
you think that life is a zero some game
no no no I mean we all do die so
everybody will die that is the only
eventuality but no I don't think that
you have to lose or win in every
situation
at all we covered practically anything
dra you want let's see here if there's
any other cover everything in more nice
what's your biggest insecurity um what's
my biggest insecurity you guys want me
to tell you a funny one
yeah uh I have really long toes so for
the people on the internet cuz feet
really get people going I don't show
them on the I have like finger toes and
so it's not really a real insecurity
it's just funny the team makes fun of me
because I wiggle them a lot when we're
presenting how how big are the toes like
can you like like I mean they're just
like
this doesn't work but yeah they're like
I have longer toes I can pick things up
with them you that's not in security
that's a okay fine you want a real
feature it's
a you know Cody Sanchez comes with
finger toes he has uh toe fingers Gavin
has these things called tingers oh my
you do wa I we're like Spirit Animals
but
opposite tingers you want to show the
camera real quick just take St okay
we'll do yeah show show The tingers Man
Show the tingers that's so funny um a
real insecurity
um my biggest insecurity is that I'm not
enough that I haven't achieved enough
that I haven't done enough that um you
know that the next thing that's in front
of me will be the thing that takes me
down and I think um I think that's why I
achieve things in life it's this Con
Conant search for validation of
capability not necessarily peers but
just capability it's common theme that
we see with really high Achievers is
that they feel like they're not enough
and I heard something I think it was V
ramaswami who said his biggest strength
is also his big biggest weakness I think
that very much applies in this case do
you ever feel like that's something that
you'd like to conquer or are you find
compromising maybe this sense of like
you know fulfillment or whatever being
enough to achieve these things that you
want to achieve I only look to overcome
things like that if I feel like they are
a negative use case to my life so if I
felt like me striving for more meant
that I let relationships fall meant that
I was letting myself get sick then I
would strive to overcome it but you
don't feel like you're com compromising
any part of happiness or Joy or
fulfillment by feeling like you may not
be
enough my Pursuit of Happiness is found
in the chase of enough and uh you know
Arthur Brooks talks about happiness a
lot and he's been somebody that I've
looked up to for years and part of a
think tank that he used to run called Ai
and um and he talks about the The
Pursuit of Happiness being multifaceted
H but one of the biggest Pursuits of
happiness is Pursuit of Happiness and so
I think Pursuit of Happiness actually
means doing the thing that you are
called to do there I don't think there
is this Blissful State I will ever have
well I will be pinking sunflowers and
dancing in fields that will achieve
happiness and I and I actually find that
a lot of the people that strive for that
uh see I mean it's creating dissonance
between where you are and where
happiness lies yeah I don't know I think
um I'm quite happy in the pursuit of
happiness but I I am I assume at some
point you know actually I don't I assume
that there is no 100% happy I have never
met a human that I feel like is 100%
fulfilled at all times maybe a child um
but I don't profess to regress to
Childhood um and so I'm happy with the
the pursuit of enough I think but the
other thing that I think is true more
than anything else is that any human you
guys have on here talk to us in 30 years
or 40 years because uh I have found that
the ideas that were strongly held at 10
at 20 at 30 change materially with
really only one input which is age um
and so maybe there will be a joy that I
find in enoughness with time as that
goes on to break down your personality
also we'll try to do this quickly cuz
this has gone pretty long Freud I'm
trying to understand mhm would you say
that higher than average intelligence
was a big factor in you getting to where
you are today no but I've never taken an
IQ test I have no idea how smart I am
you don't think that that played a role
no I I don't actually think of myself as
as smart at all okay but but here's the
thing you're so smart that you realize
your own limitations so by you saying
that you're not smart makes and you know
you're smart you're also being humble
I'm not really that humble or nice I'm
pretty honest um I think that I am
competent um and I suppose what does
smart mean do we intelligence maybe just
like computing power ability to adapt
raw horse power yes um I mean I did very
normal on my SATs and GMAT which I think
are two levels of of intellect um I
think I'm above average in ability to
take ideas translate them into words
more simply defined so maybe I might
even perceived as be perceived as more
intelligent than I am because I'm good
at speaking uh like idea to word
combination um Bill actually calls this
uh humans that have subject to verb Ava
ability which basically just means
anybody who can talk um but uh so no I I
guess I don't think about it as
intelligence but I don't think about
that that often what I do know is that I
have a very high pain tolerance for
continuing in a work perspective little
pain tolerance probably physically but I
don't think there are very many people
that can outwork me and I think it's
very hard to win against people who are
obsessed and who work continuously so
you would say it's grit and then you
also mentioned earlier that it wasn't
necessarily that you were always this
way but it was that you tried a bunch of
different veins and you finally found
the one thing that was easy for you to
outwork everyone else in yeah so if
you're saying for any viewer right now
if they want to learn how they can put
themselves in a position maybe that they
want to be in a very successful position
it's just to continue trying and testing
a bunch of different
veins IQ doesn't have much to do with it
yeah and then find something that's easy
for you to to work in yeah I think
that's well summarized I think curiosity
paired with grit paired with iteration
over long periods of time equals success
I mean I met this guy Joffrey Kent who's
maybe become another mentor of mine
because he's like a renaissance man you
know he's in his 80s he created abomi
and in Kent and the keep in touch with
him I do that's funny she mentioned she
sat next to him on a plane yeah I met
him on airan um yeah we're going to go
to Monaco this summer and see him um but
uh he mentioned that the only reason he
thinks he's been successful over time is
that he ran ABIA in Kent for 61 years
and so he just said you know time plus
compounding plus consistency equals
success um and now we all have
survivorship bias so maybe that wasn't
exactly it for him but it stuck with me
well there you have it everybody there's
the rest be to become rich I have one
final thing word
association I always enjoy doing
this psychologist major I mean that's
the stuff I'm currently interested in
okay I'm going to say something and you
tell me the first thing that comes to
your mind okay okay like one word
response let just but if I say something
like you know placard I don't want to
hear you say you know like hogen light
bulb like I want it to be have some you
know what I mean okay okay Alex Orosi uh
great friend Chris uh my husband H work
uh fun money lots of it that's good
Freedom we need more subscribe now good
one that's good I like that that was
great Chris Williamson other
friend who else do we have Lea hor MOSI
oh she's
awesome drum
Powell not great try not to say anything
terrible Grant Cardone I don't know him
Trump thank you so much for coming on
the ice coffe hour means so much
everybody listening right now please
subscribe CU we're beating Caleb hammer
in a race million subscribers sub but
it's kind of just like rotating he's
kind of beating us a little bit we're
beating him a little bit shout out to
Chris Williamson I don't know why I keep
doing this it's just such a good
beverage he not paying us to say this
thank
you